open an executive session for health
human services and elderly affairs
in case there's anyone in the audience
from the general population who has
never been in an executive session
before
it differs somewhat from a hearing in a
hearing people come to the witness table
and speak and sometimes we ask questions
in an executive session
the visitors
are not given the opportunity to speak
there is one exception to that and that
is as we are deliberating on a bill if a
member of the committee
would like something clarified by a
lobbyist a member of the department and
so on with the permission of the chair
we may call that person up to the table
but don't be confused it's not a hearing
no pink cards and so on but we're glad
you're here in any way
first up
we will be taking
house bill 1642
we are not necessarily going to do these
bills in order sometimes we do them
because of the availability
of
individuals with whom we may wish to
speak
so house bill
1642 relative to lead testing in
children
cheer calls on representative canuck to
present his amendment
thank you chair uh and thank you for
moving this forward the reason we moved
it forward is that ms beverly drewn who
is the director of the lead program i'm
not quite sure if that's the proper
title but was able to be here this
morning we went under here in case we
had any questions so just to review
uh excuse me yes sir you just moved your
amendment
i wasn't sure you said to explain so i
thought okay yes i will therefore move
amendment number zero two zero two two
zero four four three h
and second
representative woods yes representative
canarque we've been together for six
years you know to listen to what i'm
thinking
oh yeah my esp wasn't working well
anyway so
when we i had the hearing i remember the
bill initially said i did a couple
things that added a lead test in as a
requirement for daycares for schools and
also had some mandatory reporting from
providers but we identified that the
problem is that there was no
appropriation to cover these these costs
to the department
so basically what the amendment does is
it strips out sections three and four
that was the provider stuff
it keeps in sections one and two
oh by the way to make it easy this is a
replace all
so you don't need to be going back and
forth between the amendment and the bill
and figure out what line does what
the amendment
now becomes the bill
just to make it easier uh anyway
so then in the sections one and two
which were the school requirement
cuts out the reporting because that way
we don't have to worry about an
appropriation and it therefore only adds
the requirement of a blood level test on
the
physical examination that goes in for
somebody going into the school system
and the health forum for child care
and this is uh really relatively
straightforward i should point out
i should say what happened and evolved
over a period of time here was
simplifying this and then getting the
child care agencies involved to get
their point of view on this
and actually also some fqhcs to get
and
i also reached out to a number of the
physicians who work with the lead
program there already is in existence
a new hampshire early childhood health
assessment record form and it already
has on it fields to be filled out by the
provider for the blood level tests
so it really doesn't add a whole lot of
work because that field is there they
just have to transfer the number in
now
the point of this is that if the child
then the child has to have that blood
level test for admission
however
you sure don't want somebody to get
their one those coveted daycare spots
and suddenly not be able to use it
because they haven't got a lead test
done
so i also put in uh and you'll notice
this language in uh line
10 and 11 for school and in 25 and 26
for child care that if the child has not
had a blood level test at the time of
admission they'll be granted six months
to remedy the deficiency obviously when
they're applying they're going to
probably be informed about it so they
would have a few more months but still
if something happens to open up we don't
want to keep somebody out of daycare
keeping their parent out of work for
something like this
so at the end of the day they have a an
exemption
for a to remedy the deficiency for about
six months
the other thing is that i
did um
where was it here yeah that
sorry my apologies here for a moment oh
yes we also changed the age because
generally well child checks for the one
year
begin at about nine months and so
on page sorry line 24
we changed it from one year to nine
months and and also got rid of that
language of
all children because some children go as
early as six weeks and you never test
kids that early so the bottom line is
the earliest they would be expected
would be the nine months
and uh again they're exempted for a
period of time
uh and it's to remember that there is a
an exemption that already exists anyway
people do not have to do this they can
exempt
out of this and that is on line 11
and line uh
24 25
it says unless the child is exempted
under rsa 130 a5c that's already in
statute the issue is that i wanted to
reiterate it here so somebody didn't say
no you must have it if they are exempted
they're exempted they do not have to
have this on the form
so that's what the amendment does um i
did reach out to dr schessler who's the
president of new hampshire chapter of
the american academy of pediatrics and
they support the bills and then did they
think this is a very reasonable
requirement and agree that it's going to
be easy with the form that they have
with fields to be filled out
so
that's it
representative weber
you mr chairman and i will just point
out that there is a small typo
granted and so that that can be fixed by
ols either prior to voting on or as an
enrolled bill amendment so that we will
not be actually grating children for six
months yeah sorry i meant to point that
out that yeah it's graded they're graded
rather than granted we test their blood
in ways other than right
i'm sorry what was that a question sir
oh no
okay i must uh
cherish uh wishes to
ask a question um
i think most of my caucus was
looking at the
large expenditure of money on the
original bill right
thinking that that money
would better be spent actually removing
that oh yeah
so would you speak to the money issue
because this could be quite important
yes uh we did have a person who came and
testified on that very true but first of
all to remember the money issue is gone
that's the whole point of this amendment
because the costs
that were in this bill in the fiscal
note were the cost to the department
to do all of the reporting and all the
new databases
that's why i removed all this because i
knew there was no chance we were going
to get an appropriation
at this point in time in a non-budgetary
year
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
so the point of this is this completely
removes the financial issue to begin
with
how practically would it do that
there's no reporting requirement
is there someone in the audience uh who
can speak to
knowledgeably speak to this bill uh on
this very question you look oh several
knowledgeables come on up
yes and once again apologies for the
chairs they have the relative height of
them has no significance
and actually while i'm
also in terms of the first part you ask
how they're getting up there the cost
again there's no money in it but the
cost to remediate lead of all of the
most vulnerable housing in this state
would be somewhere around a billion
dollars and i'm not sure we're going to
be appropriating that either but beverly
drewen can speak to that better
good morning my name is beverly drewen
and i'm the administrator of the healthy
homes and lead poisoning prevention
program i'm here with gail gettings this
morning the health outreach coordinator
for the program who's a child
development specialist get closer to the
mic you've asked me to speak about the
fiscal note that was associated with
reporting
so currently in the state of new
hampshire all bloodlet data is reported
to the department from the medical
providers either the commercial
laboratories or the individual provider
offices
so in the original bill it had blood
lead reporting coming in from the day
cares and from the school systems this
would have been blood lead data that we
already had and it would have been
duplicative reporting
and there was also portions of the
fiscal note that required
setting up secure transport mechanisms
to transfer system has been
removed and therefore the cost of it
and therefore the costs associated with
any data reporting data storage data
manipulation
any of the data portion okay
any further questions for representative
canaric
in that case the chair calls a recess
and asks for 10 minutes for a republican
caucus in the back room
um
a5c yeah go ahead if you've got it okay
she got it 130 a 5c blood lead testing
all parents or guardians should i read
the entire thing or just the exemption
part exemption
a child shall be exempted from this
required blood level testing if a parent
or legal guardian objects to such
testing and provides a statement to such
effect
or if a physician licensed under rsa 329
or a physician exempted under rsa 329 21
3 certifies that the blood level test
blood level test level testing may be
detrimental to the child's health the
latter exemption shall only exist for
the length of time that in the opinion
of the position the testing would be
detrimental to the child the
commissioner shall develop an opt-out
form for the purpose of the section and
shall make such a form available to
health care facilities the form shall
include simple opt-out language in a
font and size easily readable by the
average adult reader
right and again that's so that's already
in statute the issue is the only reason
i inserted it here because it wasn't
initially i wanted to make sure it was
clear that this did not supersede that
exemption that that exemption still
stands
so the point is parents are mandated to
have a blood level test done by age one
year and by age two years but our
compliance has been rather poor a number
of reasons uh part of it cova does not
help secondly there was a big recall on
the finger stick blood level test
testing
device which is what's usually used in
the office rather than doing a venous
stick if you've ever done a venous stick
and a one-year-old is not fun so
at the end of the day a lot of them have
fallen behind so we understand there's
some things that may be fluky but our
compliance has not been that good since
this one into effect about three years
ago or so so the goal is simply to get
the compliance up so it's another point
of contact where you remind parents and
that they need to go get this test done
but again this does not supersede the
exemption that already exists in law
anyone else for the representative
you may speak one other thing i'm really
sorry i didn't make it clear the whole
point of this amendment as i said was to
was to get rid of the appropriation
because there was no appropriation so
the purpose of the amendment was to cut
out everything that cost money so that
they didn't have to do that
as secretary of state david scanlan says
when you're winning you can stop talking
yep well i don't know
it seemed like i failed to make it clear
the first time
would the clerk call the roll please on
amendment
2022-044
amendment to house bill 1642
as
moved by representative canuck and
seconded by representative wood
representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative renzolo
representative delemus
yes representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
absent representative knurk yes
representative soloway representative
cannon yes representative nutter upham
yes representative shapiro
representative woods yes representatives
merchant yes representative pearson yes
20 to zero the chair
um
asks of representative kenner to make a
motion
i would like to move otp a with
amendment zero four four three h
and do we have somebody over here who
might like to second it
representative gay
we have before us
now house bill 1642 as amended
by
amendment
three h 2022-0438
by representative canarch seconded by
representative
gay
and we can have further discussion
and that would be
representative leon thank you mr
chairman um i did pull up the opt-out
form and it's actually quite beautiful
um it has a check box that says i choose
not to have my child tested for an
elevated blood love level and then it
has an understanding of exactly what it
does and why you might want to have that
information there's a similar checkbox
for the for the physician and then it
has a date patient name parent guardian
name signature
the attending physician name and
signature if necessary and a witness
name and witness signature i think it's
an elegant solution and i'm glad that's
what's in place here
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman i i'm wondering
representative kanark if you know
um
i don't see any language to require that
the form be offered
or
there for it to be disclosed to
the parent that they have a right to opt
out
is there any provision for that well
remember the place may i answer
yes that the place where the testing is
done
when you're getting permission to do
that is in the provider's office and
that's where that form would be offered
it's not it's not part of this
follow up um
do you know if that's routinely offered
or is it presented as just something
that needs to be done with no option of
declining
having not been a pediatrician
working at this point perhaps beverly
drewen could answer the question as to
if she knows but i mean it's
this is kind of routine i i really don't
think there's any deception going on
it's just people are have that choice
may i answer one more i i um
i appreciate that and i understand that
i just have
discomfort with mandating and this is
strengthening a mandate by you know
adding a new um
layer of enforcement where
you know we're having the schools now
ask for this
and i just feel
that
you know on principle we need to be
careful with
requiring and mandating things of people
especially if there's no
assurance that they know that they can
opt out
representative canarch well again it's
already been in statute since 2018
system's been working very well i do not
know the number that have exemptions
that we have that was actually that
reporting was going to be part of the
original bill that again was cut because
of costs
i do not
see any pediatricians in the audience
who can tell us how they routinely do
that that would be an end of one so that
wouldn't really help us a whole lot
but
i
i assume it's part of their standard
their standard work this is so it's not
really adding a mandate this is really
the mandate's already there
um and it has to be reported and it's
the law that they have to have it done
unless they're exempted
perhaps answer for us if she knows how
the usual function goes
uh sorry about that so as representative
knuck
mentioned rsa 130a which is the lead law
here in the state of new hampshire
mandates that a child have a blood lead
test at one and again at two years old
when a family goes to a health care
provider for their well child check
they're not only having this finger
stick blood lead test
but they're having their other
immunizations i cannot speak to the
workflow in a provider's office because
i'm not a medical provider
but i do know that the opt out is part
of their
electronic management record system
and that they have those opt-out forms
there and families routinely opt out not
only of lead poisoning but though that
families don't have to fill out a form
to
object to immunizations in the doctor's
office so i i just
is this something that's routinely
you know that they present to the
parents when they go for the lead
testing oh it's required by state law
but we do have
um this opt-out form i have three
children
and
two of which are
under five well five and under and i
have never seen that form presented or
the option to opt out
made clear to me so
and i've had a couple of different
pediatricians so i just want i
understand that
i you know i understand the need for
kids to to be lead tested and
it's a good practice and i think the
best way to
get people to do things is by educating
them and i'm just wondering
um you know it wasn't being
we need this bill because
there wasn't a lot of compliance right
so now we're adding
um an additional layer where the schools
are going to ask for the proof
to increase compliance and i just want
to make sure that it's clear to parents
that they
they have a choice
representative cushman i might suggest
we deal exactly with the need of this
specific bill and perhaps you could file
an lsr
next september that would mandate
doctors to do what you ask
okay
thank you
any further questions for representative
canark
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman just uh
information for the committee
um while i'm in favor of this
legislation i want to point out that
this is a time limited process that over
time we will see lead abatement and the
problem of lead toxicity will in fact
disappear this is not unlike other
issues which we face on this committee
now there are problems that we are
legislating on that will disappear and
we're going to have statutes on the
books that are anachronisms that we have
to go back and we have to undo just an
awareness please
would i ask
since the figure of i think a billion
dollars was floated to get rid of lead
um while i grant there will be abatement
you and i may not live to see it
with all due respect sir to
representative mckay i don't expect to
live long enough to see that happen but
he has set an example that one in fact
can
so perhaps sir you will be granted the
time to see this problem go away
your lips to god's ears perhaps the next
generation will deal with the issue of
no longer needed and do it with great
rejoicing representative woods
oh thank you mr chair uh the the testing
has two parts it's it's uh preventive
uh and actually allows focused
abatement
such that your dollar is being spent for
abatement if all the money is spent just
on abatement while the the kids that are
being
uh exposed that's permanent
so though the damage will have already
been done
the point of the bill is is preventive
so that you don't even need that but
farther on
if the child i mean and this occurs
during the first year or two of life and
that's permanent
then the state may have a responsibility
special educational needs
and the trickle down because of that so
indeed this is a measure of prevention
number one and in fact provides for
focused abatement thank you mr chair are
you saying that to some degree this
actually may save money
absolutely wow
anyone else representative kanark yes
but the point is that some old housing
is
is actually uh being lived in by old
people um since it's a neurologic
developmental thing i think if i got
lead poisoning no one would notice
i'm glad that wasn't a question
anyone else
good we have
before us are you ready for the question
once again 1642
as amended by 2022-043-h
the amendment
and this was moved by representative
canark and seconded by representative
gay clerk please call the roll
thank you representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes
representative renzullo
representative delemus
yes
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes twenty to one
twenty to one do you object to put this
on consent
representative cushman
no objection it goes on consent
representative canark please
give me a blurb
already done
wow
let that be a model
one
is done
that closes the exact session on 1642
open an exec session now on
house bill
1654 yes we are taking this out of order
because the initial uh prime sponsor is
in the room and has to get off to
another committee
and the chair recognizes representative
king for a motion
i would like to move that we
do an interim study on this
you move interim study
that is by representative king who would
like to second that representative
soloway
and representative king please speak to
your motion
so over the weekend we we worked on this
and i think we came very close
um but i think that there's still some
language that we still need to work on
and uh we
we feel that this is a very important
bill and
we'd just like to have a little bit more
time with it
representative leon thank you mr
chairman um this this is very important
and because it may cost a decent amount
of money we need to get it right the
first time and make sure that if there
are any funds which we had heard word of
um that we make use of them in order to
provide the best data possible and get
this right done right so that we can
actually know what's happening in our
state
so
this is one of those things that we
worked very very hard on i i'm very
impressed that we came so close to
coming to agreement but we need to get
the correct data and as we're working on
it it would do a disservice to
collect it not quite in the right way or
in a more expensive way than we
otherwise could collect the data because
this is very important for public health
i am encouraged that in a study we would
have more standing to get the cdc
guidelines to the states on their best
practices that they found with the other
47 states that do collect these data
and by doing that we may be able to have
one that perhaps california and maryland
can follow our lead once we implement a
best practice to collect these data
any further discussion
remember this is an exact session it
does not have to be in a form of a
question
we've had good practice at not doing it
as a question while we were having
hearings so now you can really do it
legally if you wish
seeing no
sharings or questions
are we ready to vote
the motion is interim study on house
bill 1654
as moved by representative king
and seconded by representative soloway
would the clerk please call the rule
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative renzolo
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
any objection to consents none
representative king thank you for
getting the committee report uh from
yesterday to me in a timely manner and
now you get a chance to do another one
thank you consent calendar consent yes
oh you did that sorry
i'm still taking notes well you're
multitasking very well
that concludes the
exec session on 1654.
next up will be 11
30.
open the executive session on house bill
you should have before you
an amendment you will see oh yeah
you should
soon
have an amendment before you from
representative weber
she's getting the rest passed out
and representative as a wordsmith this
is very good tight prose
please take a look at it and before we
discuss it
i will call for someone to move it but
look at it first
you've looked at it it's very tight pros
the chair calls on representative weber
for a motion
not everybody
as it's going around i'll just explain
it but it is coming in both directions
would you make a motion first please i'm
getting there
um
mr chairman i would like to move uh
amendment zero five
eight please
representative
webber is there a second
representative kelsey
does everyone have the amendment in
front of
not just
not
just going by anybody else
need one there are some
now we have two for everyone
we found a stash
but i just thought i'd say thank you
well that's very nice thank you for that
okay okay okay
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
representative leon for working on this
together
uh the
very tight amendment makes two small
changes the first is would the change
would be on line 29 and 30 of the first
page of the original bill
and it would be lines three four and
five on the amendment
the original bill had an exception that
you did not need to allow access
if
the
access would create a hazard for the
patron
but
the concern that people had was also
uh
the risk to an employee who might be
working alone might have to guard
pocketbooks might have
other reasons for concern about safety
so
we added risk to the employee as well
the second thing we did because we
thought that
a fine of a thousand dollars is a lot of
money to a small business and even a
medium-sized small business
and we're a little ambiguous about who
has to be allowed in and who doesn't
so we thought that putting that kind of
a fine out there
was really unfortunate and so
uh
because misunderstandings happen
particularly when people are
in urgent need
and so um
yes we have created a bill that doesn't
have any teeth in it
but we are urging compliance we hope to
use it as a tool for education for the
public
and i would
urge you to adopt the amendment and then
adopt the bill and i'd be glad to take
any questions any questions for the
representative
this was the sticky spot as you remember
when we first heard it and it looks like
we're unstuck representative acton
i have more of a comment um i'd like to
thank the
uh thank you mr chair by the way um
i would like to thank the prime sponsor
for working with uh
with us on this the
the testimony was was
was heart-wrenching where people would
be in an emergency in a store
and they would be denied and then
get into
trouble
that couldn't stand but the
the fine i felt was too much and so
removing that brings me to a point where
i support this and and
also the idea of of educating and
communicating
and um is is so much better than just
compliance just do this
so i hope we can start building a way
that we can
communicate out to the business
community out to the various communities
rather than
than just legislating but this bill i
think is a great compromise and i'll be
proud to vote for it thank you
anyone else representative leon thank
you mr chairman um and thank you
representative weber for working with me
and with us on this to try and find a
way to soften this mandate on businesses
it is a mandate but it's one that
doesn't have enforcement and it allows
somebody to if if they need to if they
feel unsafe they have a chance to dodge
and put that on their employer so
they're not saying
i would but you look big and scary and
i'm all by myself so i believe that by
approaching it this way
they're able to
you're able to still respect the rights
on both sides of the aisle those who are
about to have a very serious bathroom
emergency and those who may
you know there are front line workers
they're the people who have been at the
face of all of this they've been
harassed both sides back and forth with
covent the last thing i want to do is
pin anything else on them but we can't
do that at the expense of these people
these people that have a real need
so i think that this is a very nice
compromise and walks that line um
especially because i don't know any
other education out um outreach that
would be able to make business owners
and employees aware of just how critical
this is
anyone else
house bill 2022-0542-h
[Music]
has been moved by representative webber
and seconded by representative kelsey
this is a vote on the amendment would
the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative renzullo representative
delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
21-0 i hope no objection to consent
that was only the amendment
would you believe i was testing to see
who was awake
i wouldn't
it was just a housekeeping matter
now
would someone like to move
the bill is amended representative weber
thank you mr chairman i would be
delighted to move um
house bill 1130 uh ought to pass as
amended by amendment zero five four two
h would someone like to second it from
all right representative delemus
anybody wish to speak
we ready to vote
and we will be voting on house bill 1130
as amended by
amendment 2022-0542h
the bill is amended has been moved by
representative weber and seconded by
representative delemus
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative franzulo
representative
representative weber yes representative
mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
and now for a brilliant if somewhat
misplaced earlier statement any
objection to consent
thank you
and representative weber on the
committee report thank you
house bill 15 26 relative to income
eligibility
for in and out medical assistance the
chair calls on um is there there was an
amendment on this or not
we have a fiscal note that's being
passed out
a revised fiscal note
madam parliamentarian do we need to vote
on a revised fiscal note no absolutely
not we just receive it
okay let's receive it and then
representative snow i'll call on you for
a motion okay
not yet no yeah we want to see the
fiscal note just yet okay just just
looking at it
we can do it either way
coming
okay how many pages here it should be
just one two pages
um
no what we are not on that bill
we're on this bill and i see one page
and
turn over to the other side
okay that's for later okay
you should make sure that what you have
is in the upper right lba 22-2110
that's what you should see
and by the way many of you will have in
your notes this exact information with
crossouts on the previous fiscal note we
talked about it but here it is in true
hard copy
now representative snow you are
recognized for a motion
this is a relatively simple bill in a
way
what we're basically it's really three
words repeal the suspension is really
what we're doing
just by way of background during the
last session we passed a bill the senate
passed that the governor signed it and
it actually became the lead bill in that
long list of health care bills that went
in
and it basically says that individuals
low-income individuals
who are
have an income that's somewhat in excess
of this threshold for medicaid
eligibility
may become eligible
if i'm sorry
oh
she was assembling this it wasn't
hearing
that
it gives the department of health and
human services the right to look at what
goes on and if a person is ongoing
and overwhelming medical expenses that
they couldn't possibly meet with the
current income they have they can
qualify for what we call medi in and out
medical assistance
and it allows people to then draw on
funds from the medicaid account
assuming that a certain spend down is
met to bring them down to that threshold
and it's very important because that
threshold
has never been ingested in 30 years it
went back to 1990 when that threshold
was established and i think we can all
agree
that the cost of living has changed
somewhat substantially in the last 30
years which leads you to say
i move i move that we pass
house bill 1526.
thank you
is there a second second thank you
representative mcmahon a co-sponsor
now further discussion
or
questions or statements
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
when i look at this i always have the
caution about how much we're expanding
things but this is one of the areas
where
not having not having this threshold and
not having this in and out
opportunity keeps people from taking
jobs and it keeps them from advancing
themselves and moving out of dependency
into independence and we need to soften
the edges and i think that this softens
the edges for people and that's why i'm
supporting it
and as do i for the same reason
representative shapiro
901.
the old threshold with less than 150 a
week
to meet all your expenses
this goes somewhat above that but it's
still not living in luxury
but it's doable
representative
no one
we good
okay
we are ready to vote on house bill
1526 with a revised fiscal note
moved by representative snow
seconded by representative mcmahon
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
franzulo
representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay
representative snow yes representative
knark representative soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson
yes
i have seen 19 to 2
on consent
if you do not want it on consent you
will have to argue it from the floor
if you're prepared to do that
or do you or do the two no votes wish to
wonder
i'm sorry rep representative what
on consent well to quote
acting secretary of state scanlon
shut up
on consent thank you
what
the chair recognizes um
representative mckay i would like to
commend representative snow for his
persistence
in this legislation it's been a long
journey
for him and i
very much appreciate what he's done
we have to say over the years on this
subject thank you
thank you sir thank you the next bill in
order is 1536 we will not be taking it
up the prime sponsor asked if we not do
it between 10 and 11.
next up is house bill
1578 and the chair recognizes
representative acton for a motion
thank you mr
representative acton moves itl is there
a second
representative delamas is second
now discussion
thank you
the
the issue here is that the
eligibility requirements so forth were
worked out in a bill
several years ago
and were part of the negotiated
agreement that was voted on and made
into law
and
i found out the hard way in the past
because basically i do support a lot a
lot of the
medicaid program and i've proven that in
the past with my voting
but one thing i've learned my lesson is
to not undo
the negotiated
settlements that lead to legislation
in the next year or two i think that has
a corrosive effect on
being able to
negotiate in the future when you just
try to change it the next year or the
next year
i don't think that's a positive way of
legislating so therefore i oppose this
begrudgingly oppose this thank you thank
you representative shapiro
yes this is just a question um
i'm not sure um representative what
you're referring to in terms of a
previous negotiated um
program the current
the current
statute for
managing the
eligibility that we're about to change
was negotiated
previously
and we're trying to change that so
would you
be referring to several years ago in the
house when we first looked at medicaid
expansion
numbers of people including myself who
were inclined to vote no
voted yes because there was
a
sort of courteous understanding that we
wouldn't keep being pushed on this i i
think is that what you mean exactly i i
wasn't here for that um
negotiation but i
but that's exactly what i mean it was
also the same issue with the the work
requirement that we tried to change
uh that was negotiated that brought on a
lot of votes and it caused the passage
of the bill
to
to then change that
a year or two down the road undermines
the original agreement so
representative shapiro may follow up yes
this bill is proposed does not
specifically
refer to expanded medicaid or the
granted advantage program it refers to
medicaid in general
and it's adding
it's actually taking a federal option
that's been there for years and years
and that most states have taken
to add a very small number of
pregnant and minor immigrants
so it's not a specific change in the
expanded medicaid program that was
that was negotiated um you know for a
five-year period
well that's the the agreement
of that five-year waiting period was
is
something that has been the standard for
many years
and that's something that the people of
new hampshire and through the legislator
legislature has agreed upon so in this
current environment to change that i
don't think is a good idea
representative weber
okay i have i have several points to
make to all of that um
first of all i i second the point about
representative shapiro that this is
traditional medicaid it's not expanded
medicaid it's an option that has been
available to us
we make changes all the time in the
legislature we have negotiated
agreements all the time in the
legislature
and adding something that didn't was not
part of the original agreement
shouldn't
be an issue here
we all know that it is a
fundamental principle of legislation
that
the actions of one legislature do not
bind the next legislature and i cannot
tell you how many carelessly
negotiated and carefully worked out
agreements
that i have seen
and participated in have been undone by
the next legislature without any concern
whatsoever for the agreements that were
made earlier so that's one issue
the second issue is that if we value the
lives
of our unborn citizens
and if we value the lives
of our youngest
citizens
because these children will be born here
and they will be citizens and their
parents are in the country legally
but they're whether they're citizens or
not they're children and if we value the
lives of children would we not want to
give them the very best possible start
in this world by giving them the best of
preventive
and
well-child care in their earliest years
because we know that if we do not do so
we are being
very penny wise and exceedingly pound
foolish because
when they show up in an emergency room
they will receive treatment
and it will be paid for by the taxpayers
so
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound
of cure and i will be voting against the
itl thank you mr chairman
thank you representative leon
thank you mr chairman
when we heard this bill i definitely
heard i felt for all of these families
but both of the cases that were brought
to us had one thing in common um they
they had declared amnesty but that
amnesty was after a immigrant detention
which means that when they entered they
weren't declaring amnesty
i
i would be interested in seeing a much
more narrowly crafted one where we're
respecting those that when they set foot
here say i am here for help i am the
poor the unwashed the needy who have
reached out to the united states in
order to find hope
uh extending it to those who declare
i i think what would be a reasonable
compromise but that's that's such a
large thing to do it's not something we
can rewrite in an early bill
i feel for these families but i also
fled a state where compassion is
bankrupting the health care system and
at a certain point you have to
understand
what costs people can bear
what cost people should bear and as you
start opening more and more things up it
just keeps growing
and right now there's in my in my birth
state i won't call it my home state
because new hampshire is my home now and
forever but in my birth state there
there's problems with access to care
because it's been opened up so wide
i i
i can't support something that that's
crafted so wide that once you're caught
then suddenly you qualify for care i i
think that crafting it more narrowly so
when you come here asking for help as
soon as you enter that's the sort of
thing that we can reach out to first and
see what the impact is
representative snow i maybe my memory
sometimes plays tricks but it's my
recollection that people who arrive in
the united states as refugees already
qualify for medicaid coverage for some
period of
is time
is that
am i correct about that i believe i am
is anybody here that can answer that
so in essence what we're doing is we're
not changing the law we're simply
broadening it to include other people
who are legally
here but not as refugees but green cards
that arrive for other reasons
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman so for a little
background
representative snow is correct people
who come
through one of the resettlement agencies
as vetted refugees from refugee camps
and other places in the world
come
with
full
full federal benefits available to them
um and as an example the afghan evacuees
who 60 000 have come in
recent months they are not full-fledged
refugees but they've given been given
expedited
um
status so that they that all of this
will be available to them
um
i think you probably were referring to
asylum seekers rather than amnesty
um i may be incorrect but
um
possibly it's uh about the terms but but
the question is is intent on entry right
so um asylum seekers are people who
request asylum in this country
because
going back to their
home country
will involve some kind of serious
persecution and they have to pass a
credible fear interview which starts off
the process
and i think that
and then they have to make a long
application with um information about
the persecution that they experienced
and frequently those
final hearings to declare whether they
get
um asylum or not takes
um one of the lawyers said 10 or 15
years i've heard more like
two or three years but i guess it varies
um
but i think none of us would say
that the immigration system as is works
um well
i think that's something we could all
agree on that the immigration system as
is
does not work well
and so therefore
things are always changing things are
transient
people make application for
asylum
people get sent to detention and it's
not always so logical
um
i i guess my point is
i guess i'm really disappointed and i
think that um
you know as
representative weber alluded to i think
we have real heartfelt differences on
certain issues i'm wading into shark
infested waters here i'm talking about
abortion
but i thought we had really broad
support
for
people who are pregnant and want to
bring children into the world
people who are children and who are
vulnerable who don't have money
and um
i thought i thought there was very broad
support on this
committee
to support those people who wanted to
make a go of it in this country
and i'm just really disappointed
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman everybody else
i think we're losing sight of what's
really important here
there are two individuals
that we're talking about one's the
mother who could be here illegally
whatever status may be
the other one's the child
it's the fetus that which she carries
and that child ultimately will become a
u.s citizen
so therefore are we shooting ourselves
in the void because we're not making the
investment
in that child
which may come out
with all kinds of concerns we talk about
lead testing and so forth probably
they're living in a house with lead in
it
should we try to find a way to make that
an investment not an expense but an
investment in that child so they become
a productive citizen of the state
who can contribute to the state
not focus on the mother and the status
of the mother i'd ask you to focus on
the child
who is soon to become a u.s citizen and
have all the rights
of a u.s citizen
that they're entitled to including
health care in medicaid
so it's not so much i look at this as an
expense but rather
an investment that we make into that
child
so they in fact do become a productive
citizen of our state
i saw representative connerk
yes i just wanted to uh comment a little
bit about the agreement on sb 313 which
was the medicaid reauthorization in 18.
i spent countless hours on this the
triumvirate of jess edwards bill marsh
and i brought forward 10 amendments on
that bill when we came through our
committee
um and yes the work requirement was a
really big compromise and that's why i
voted against representative mc williams
bill two years ago because i did not
think we should go back on our
compromise
but i don't recall the issue of
uh asylum seekers
or
people who are refugees
while refugees already kind of
asylum seekers being a big bone of
contention or a bargaining chip on that
uh that was the work requirement so
i don't feel bound by the
work we did in 2018 though i do in
principle do and that's why
i did not vote against the work
requirement i voted against the broker
requirement appeal when it came up
because i wanted to honor the
requirement so i think that
representatives comments i think
shouldn't drive it i think it more
important is that issue of an investment
in the future by keeping kids healthy
and if
representative weber said
kids get sick they're going to show up
in the uw
we have an obligation we're not going to
tell them i'm sorry
we're not going to treat you because
you're the wrong person we're going to
take care of them and that that cost is
going to come straight from the taxpayer
at a much higher cost than it would if
we gave them preventive care
representative nada upham
well call me sentimental but i'm in
favor of taking care of pregnant women
and children no matter where they're
from
i've been the recipient when i lived in
england for a year of having
a pregnancy emergency and a doctor came
and did a house call to my little
apartment and charged me nothing and i
said oh i should pay something i mean
they have universal health care
i don't know if that helps but
i'm in favor of voting for this bill
this is accessing
a federal program
that is taking up some of the cost
and this isn't going to be hundreds of
thousands of people i mean i think this
is going to be a small sampling of
people in new hampshire
and i don't think it's gonna break our
bank
representative leon
thank you mr chairman i appreciate this
dialogue and thank you for letting me
know that refugees are already covered
i'm delighted to know that because
because that's the right thing to do
i i'm not i'm trying i need to we need
to balance the compassion
for
all of these families that are starting
out i speak to so many families that are
on the bubble they're on the cusp every
single increase is the sort of thing
where they're choosing between
more hours away from their kids or what
kind of food they're putting on the
table especially with this
incredible inflation that we're seeing
right now they're just they're having to
balance gas and this is the sort of
thing that impacts our other families
where they are also bringing children
into the world and considering whether
they will and
possibly choosing not to even after the
pregnancy has started because they can't
afford that child
our compassion for one group of people
can't be at the expense of others and i
do know that we have us we have charity
care and we need to make sure that that
it does remain robust
when it's a small group of people
we can as a community reach out and help
them and we do have ways ways to do that
i i just can't let compassion for one
small group of people end up
increasing the costs on these other
families that are working so hard
they're on the bubble and they're
already dealing with inflation we
haven't seen at least in my lifetime
and the idea of expanding this when
we're not
expanding this in in such a way i
realize there's federal funds but those
don't come without state funds
and we are also all federal taxpayers as
well and our families that are strapped
that may not be as privileged as you and
i
they feel every one of these increases
and it it impacts how they care for
their children it impacts their prenatal
nutrition in their own pregnancies and
we can't we can't be blind to those
costs too and that that that's why i do
remain against this and i do see that as
an issue of compassion because we can
still provide
charity care we still can reach out to
these families that's something that
this country has long done reaching out
to those who need help on an individual
basis and not always sticking it on
their neighbors who might not afford it
so i
i appreciate the heart and the
compassion on both sides i appreciate
the prenatal needs
but i just can't put this on my
struggling families
representative snow
both the refugee and this new bill does
put time limits on how long that
benefits last
and in this bill it says
the mother is covered through her
pregnancy and the postpartum period
which now is 60 days and if we pass that
other bill it'll be 12 months that
they'd be coming and then it stops but
these things are built in because it's
expected that people that receive these
benefits will be motivated to move
towards becoming more self-sufficient in
earning those benefits not
accepting them as gifts
same thing with the refugees i don't
know exactly what the time limit is but
i know that the refugees have
for some i don't know how many months it
is but they have a time limit on how
long they can go and they need to find a
way
to find insurance or an alternative way
to do it
so i think
you you have to look at the fact that
this is also a motivator
to move people towards independence
it's it's it's really
the road back
not a dead end
representative shapiro
yes um i know we can all read but um i
just would like to make the point that
we're talking about
four hundred and forty thousand dollars
a year half of which will be covered by
um the federal government which is two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year to make a real difference in
a lot of people's um
in a significant number of people's
lives um and um in their starting off in
life and um
once again i would just say that it's
we're talking about 220 000 in state
funds
representative
and as a follow-up to that i'd like to
point out that one of the most important
things that we see with good prenatal
care is the prevention of premature
birth and a premature birth let's say
two months early and in the nicu for
perhaps 30 days or so the cost of that
is about five times that's one
one child the cost that would be about
five times the cost of this entire bill
and guess what
no one's going to throw that child out
in the dumpster because they don't have
insurance because they're the wrong
person we're going to take care of them
we're going to pay the bill
it's actually we are losing money if we
don't pass this
prenatal care is extremely important
all of you
all of us
well all of you who are females in this
room have had the luxury if you have
children of having probably good
prenatal care
and you know how important that is and
we do know that maternal mortality
is higher with poor prenatal care
but if you don't care about the
immigrants okay that's fine but at least
the kids who are u.s citizens
that's the other group that suffers a
good friend of mine had her child at
about 28 months and was in the nicu for
60 days
and i was involved in some of the costs
that she had to face trying to help her
with that 28 weeks sorry
28 weeks yes sir thank you very much
representative salloway
hypothetical
at fort mccoy in wisconsin we have
upwards of 80 000 afghan refugees
many many of whom are pregnant women
coming into the country they will be
settling in among other places new
hampshire this is simply insurance that
we can take care of these people
preventively now so that we're not
paying for them in
much larger amounts of money later this
is good legislation we ought to pass it
representative gay
thank you i'm not sure the
courtesy
involved what currently do we have the
bill that you was just referred to
that if we pass this other bill it will
extend
from
postpartum it will extend postpartum to
12 months
what what is the comparison of that bill
to this bill what's different
about i guess it's who who is covered
representative shapiro
yes these are
two completely separate bills so this
this bill
would cover approximately
people in various immigration statuses
who are pregnant or children and it
would make them it would
remove a five-year wait
which they currently have to be eligible
for medicaid
the other bill that you're talking about
which is completely separate
but which will be coming up today will
be one that
extends
postpartum benefits from what is
currently 60 days to a full year
and that is a that is a different bill
um
it might affect some of the people who
would get
medicaid through this bill but it's
they're completely separate
seeing no further comments or questions
the motion before us
on house bill 1578 fn
is inexpedient to legislate moved by
representative acton
seconded by representative delemus would
the kirk clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes
representative renzullo
representative delemus representative
webber
representative mckay no representative
snow no representative knurk no
representative soloway no
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no representative shapiro
no representative woods no
representative merchant no
representative pearson
yes 11 to 10
11 to 10 representative
acton if you would write the majority
report and
um
ranking member who would you wish to
have
and representative shapiro for the
minority thank you sir
shapiro
and
i'm assuming your
recommended
motion will be otp
the minority report
okay i had an amendment
as well
thank you thank you
this closes the hearing on
1578 going out of
order
open the hearing on 1662.
we have an amendment by representative
soloway
so
we have to hold on this for a minute
okay
i'm advised that they caught some errors
and it's being revised so
we
will recess is that the term because i
opened up the hearing on 1662 so we will
now recess the hearing on 1662
and come back to it when we have a
revised amendment
are we taking a
break we are taking about a five to
eight minute break
can we just go to a different bill
mr chair couldn't we just go to another
bill
mr chair couldn't we just move on and do
another bill
we're taking a break okay
nope
okay what are we going to then i don't
know oh okay
i cannot do this
talking to siri at three in the morning
oh
yeah neither i don't do the forms he
gets to do the forms
yeah he doesn't
um
my sister
very safe
i've got the good stuff
is
got it
you know the lady with the
just food
falling down
that's
you're doing fine i just yeah to say
goodbye
is
uh
somehow
so watch for that
is
so we're waiting for
yet another version of this amendment
um
uh
thank you
they
of
i do a day before it was due i am so
impressed
you don't need the right one
he's writing one he's written what
that cancels out a lot of missed
microphone appointments
so we may go a little slowly
okay
ops when the music stops please find a
seat
and once you've found it please sit in
it
you should have music
open the hearing on house bill 1608
and there is only one amendment to be
under consideration it is that i know of
and it is amendment
this year dash 0537h
an amendment
by
a group of people representatives lay on
cushman and gay
and the chair calls on
someone to pass out that amendment
oh
and coming to you is amendment
this year dash
0537 h
and since it's one of these replace the
bill with this bill i'll give you a
while to read it before i call on
representative gay to make a motion but
take it take some time and read it
through
you may have several moments
i know
yes
um
uh
foreign
so
yeah that's just the rough draft
yet
the doors
okay
um
i didn't have an option
i think
yes
well i you know i use that with my wife
oh
and he should have an amendment
opening the recessed hearing on
house bill 1608
we have given everybody a chance to
read amendments
2022-0537 which replaces the whole bill
and the chair recognizes representative
gay for a motion
i make a motion that we accept we otp
amendment
20-22 0537
to house bill 1608
fn thank you
is there a second
second
representative delemus
and uh would
those of you who worked hard on this
amendment would anybody care to
tell us what this amendment does
representative gay or representative
leon well
both not at the same time
the act as you can see
um
the right of privacy was what was the
motivation for this
uh
rewrite of the bill
and people did not when they were
given immunizations in particular were
not notified that they could opt out of
being registered in the registry so this
just this was an attempt to think of the
least expensive way to notify people
that they could now opt out
and the
i don't remember if everybody even saw
the previous
amendment this just simply changed the
wording to be used in the notification
to the public
because the in the original amendment
it's
used more and
the sort of language we were expected to
be able to read but the public really
isn't
so
uh my amendment was simply to simplify
the wording
uh there was nothing to matter with the
the previous wording it just was a
little more
collegiate so we say than
high school
so the wording
changed to
the state of new hampshire obtained your
private health information without
offering you a chance to opt out that's
lines up that's on page two
our new hampshire
constitution honors your right to
privacy including your medical
information and you have the right to
withdraw your information and then it
would include a link
so they could go to the
dhhs website to easily find it
representative weber
i would just say that having having
reviewed the amendment uh i appreciate
uh that people have addressed the
concerns of those of us who do want to
voluntarily have our
information continue in the registry and
that nothing has interfered with that
but i certainly support the right of
anybody who wishes to remove their
information to do so so i appreciate the
work that's been done on the bill
representative
and i do too completely but i do have a
question the statement uh reliance on
the amendment
page two lines one through
uh five or four talk about the campaign
shall inform the public that blah blah
blah
got it
but can the wording have other
explanations because if i saw that i
would have no idea what it's talking
about it doesn't say anything about the
vaccine registry that it was it just
says you have your private health
information a person might think this is
their entire medical record that
suddenly got shipped off to the state by
accident i'm assuming this is
shall include this
shall at least include this and there
can be more explanation i would hope
that is correct is that correct
yes you make a good point but i mean but
is that correct because i mean the
reading here the wording doesn't say
shall inform them only that
it's so that is clear that it can be
more i should trust the department to
know that thank you
because it's always it's also important
that they would be able to tell them
that this is the only place that that
record exists so it's important that
more information be given that's i
should make sure they could do that
thank you representative soloway thank
you mr chairman i would simply like to
note with high praise the inclusion on
line 10
of the sentiment endorsed by our
constituents and individuals right to be
free from governmental intrusion in
private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent and that
must be a guiding principle for this
committee it will show up again later
today thank you
merchant
i want to thank the authors of the
amendment um it does the move this
clarify a lot of things for me the way i
read this if i'm correct it eliminates
the fiscal note kind of like we did
before with one of the other bills
there's not
an attachment for appropriations to
accomplish this is that correct number
two one of the things is more for
clarification having been on the board
of pharmacy for 10 years
when you put something in statute it's
very difficult for a department to
change the statute
i'm not saying they can't but the way
it's worded right now because the
language is very specific in the statute
i think it will cause confusion because
it will have to say public
health information and not specifically
vaccines so
i'm not trying to derail the amendment
but just bring it to people's attention
that when a statute is very clear that
way it's hard to change it by department
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for
all of this discussion that we're having
here the idea is to make sure that we
can get this word out in the most cost
effective manner and by using the power
of social media press releases and
making this easy to find on the website
i think we can get from here to there um
i do know that i had been able to
i wasn't able to find the opt out until
it was emailed to us so
that's why as we were working on this
amendment it was so important to say
that it needed to be prominent that it
needed to have those banners for that
time period because
i'm really good at searching online and
i still couldn't do it
i do appreciate some of these
updates to language
the idea of perhaps specifically saying
that it's regard to the covet
vaccination during a certain time period
so i don't know if that's something that
we might want to look at a little bit
more and see if we can refine it before
the before the clock runs out today
representative weber
mr chairman i wonder if before he sneaks
out the door back there we could inquire
of mr williams from the department
mr williams from the department uh could
we inquire of mr williams from the
department
whether he felt the language
that is included here
would
preclude the department have you seen
the amendment sir
lines two through four
of the amendment
but
of page two
yes that's what
that
i didn't hear it okay we are now on page
two we are on lines two to four and i'm
now going to ask my question
my question is
you are mandated by this statute to
include the the language there
but by mandating that that be included
it does not
prevent you from putting
a banner headline on all of the
information you send out saying
notice regarding the covid vaccine
registry
and putting any other
explanatory information in here as long
as these words and the hyperlink to the
current form is included is that correct
um chairman pearson that would be the
department's read of that language that
it would allow at a minimum that we
would have to include this but certainly
could be more expansive for clarity's
sake with with the public uh certainly
if the committee wanted to entertain a
further amendment on that issue they
could but i think given your read and my
read of this that we don't need a
further amendment on that section we do
appreciate the very hard work
particularly by resident leon and also
representative gay and the committee on
and
represent cushman thank you um
for
taking a bill that obviously had
significant issues for the department
and turning it into something that
certainly
more clearly addresses what i think the
committee's vision was around it however
with that said because i feel the
pressure of two wonderful people sitting
next to me there is a cost associated
with this it's not as big as obviously
the cost associated with the bill as
introduced
i do think you made big efforts not to
include a mass mailing so i personally
uh not personally my in my capacity as
director of legislation appreciate that
effort but i'm going to um ask uh with
the with the okay of the uh chair of the
committee if dr turalek could just
comment briefly because she's done
similar uh campaigns uh involving
public health and she can give you at
least an idea of what the cost may be
even though i have a feeling we may be
going a little far afield in our
conversation but just we'd be remiss if
we didn't mention that uh because we
wouldn't want it to be a surprise when
the bill moves along in the process so
with that
i would like doctor
welcome back thank you uh just for the
record my name is uh dr sai chiralla i'm
the bureau chief for the population
health uh based on this read when you
talk about some of the public campaign
most of them do cost there is a cost
associated with that kind of work and
when you're thinking about expanding
this kind of information across the new
hampshire whether we talk about social
media or others there is a cost
associated some of the campaigns similar
to that things we have done would be
around a quarter million dollars and i
understand there is a fiscal note not
associated with this so we want to think
about that cost association for that and
have a consideration from the committee
on how do we do that with the with
respect to what the committee wants us
to do
thank you
if it were the intended committee to
utilize existing resources to do exactly
what you're trying to have us to do
uh in recognition of the fact that it
may not be as robust as maybe other
campaigns that have done that have been
funded uh we just want to place that out
there uh for for your consideration
representative gay
thank you so much
excuse me
um i because i was amending a bill on an
amendment that was already there
as
in my previous life
evaluating gui's gui graphical user
interface
we tried to make things as
as intuitive as possible i didn't write
that into here but my intention was that
after we had testimony that said you can
find the vaccine registry online and
then some skilled people couldn't find
it
the
software may be half built at least
already on the website that does have
the vaccine registry on it
not totally ready obviously so we forgot
about that costing
um but what it would be i envisioned of
just a little bar on the front uh
the home page that would say vaccine
registry
and you clicked on that and there's all
more information on vaccines i'm sure
you have a lot of information about
vaccines one of the options would be
to opt out of the kofi
so i didn't write any of that into
into my modification and again we we do
believe that you've been very thoughtful
in your approach here and i think you
tried to design this in a way to
effectuate the notice to the public
around the opportunity to uh having that
removed from the registry
the concern and just hearing from dr
chirala is under similar campaigns there
have been a cost associated with it
and we'll just if there is no
appropriation we'll do the best we can
uh with no appropriation but it would be
always helpful to consider
the possibility of actually funding this
if needed to making sure that it is a
robust
campaign which i think that's what the
committee's intent is representative
weber
i have a question for clarification from
the drafters of the amendment based on
the
comments from the department
and my question has to do with the
bottom of page one and the top of page
two
on line thirty of page one it says a
notice or banner promptly displayed on
all websites operated by the department
for use by the general public
for not less than 60 days
and i wonder if that might be
over broad and burdensome
on
the department if every single
site for every single division has to
post this or whether the intent
was to tie it specifically
to just
the front page of the department's
overall website
and then
presumably follow-up links on the parts
of the website that deal with
vaccinations
i
i wonder if we could clarify
whether this would require a notice on
the front page of the division of elder
services and the division of dcyf and
i mean it says all websites so i'm a
little worried about what that means and
where where you actually want it and
what the department is required to do
the chair is asking uh
representative leon the meaning of the
word all here
thank you mr chair um the intent with
this is to make it so that when people
are interacting with the department
website it it is something that they see
whether they're going to a top level
page or they're going to one of the
programs within it
if you think back to the earlier days of
the pandemic there was a very small
pop-up at the top of all of the
department all the new hampshire
websites that gave the link to those
coveted resources
by having something that applies across
the entire domain it actually
i've only done really small websites so
people who have done larger ones let me
know but by applying a pop-up to
anything within a certain domain i've
i've been led to believe it's easier
than trying to figure out which pages
would get it so by having simply a
pop-up that expires after a certain
amount of time it actually appeared to
be a less burdensome one than trying to
insert it into
the side panel of each one of these
different groups because they don't have
the same format you'd have somebody
going in and inserting it and when you
do that i'm really good at breaking
computers and i know it can break those
websites so the idea of having that
option of that pop-up banner that then
lets people know that they have that
option
it would get it in front of eyeballs
reduce the burden and we weren't looking
for a campaign like the one i saw last
night about getting your shot and
getting boosted that is a very huge
campaign and a very very expensive one
by putting out a press release that then
has the opportunity to get picked up and
by putting out at least one post on
social media it would allow that to
circulate through those different
through those different mechanisms where
people are having this communication and
by doing this it shows that this is
coming from the department but is
intended to reduce that burden because
the press release
should be something that's relatively
routine
um posting on the social media account i
do know that there are posts um
fortunately they don't spend their whole
day like some of the police departments
or wendy's that like to interact with
the public so thank you
uh but but those do go out there and i i
i'm not sure if it'd be correct to
assume that press releases also go out
onto the social media accounts and if so
then if that's the case i'm sorry can i
respond to that question yes sure um yes
we do do press releases if you're
looking at that kind of an information
press release social media post or even
putting on our website wouldn't be a
cost factor but when you talk about a
public campaign just remember we are
from public health for us campaigns is
across the public so we are thinking you
know the bigger the boost kind of thing
but if you're looking at that kind of a
smaller thing that would be something
that we could we would be able to do
that but maybe the language has to be
modified in the amendment to focus
saying that these are the areas that we
are asking the department to do not a
public campaign so that's where we are
want to clarify
is there another word that would be more
limited than campaign to use on page one
line twenty nine
uh those public information campaign
notification
endeavor
representative connerk was next
we all we have the experts up here just
a quick question because we did receive
some federal federal funds to help us
with vaccination
and this is sort of part of our
vaccination thrust could some of those
federal funds be applied to to pay the
costs for this because
um the notification
about the opt-out is really sort of part
of our vaccination program would that be
allowable
it's a it's a very good question we do
have some federal funds but they're
focused on expanding the reach of the
vaccinations
so we have to go back and look and talk
to our federal partners on that and if i
could add the word campaign maybe the
word outreach might be in a very
effective word
representative weber
in the hopes that we don't have to
redraft this again
may i point out that what it says here
is that the campaign shall at a minimum
include
a press release the posting on the
social media account and the notice or
banner
if you can do that
you have met the minimum
and there is no further requirement for
a campaign
that is more
than the minimum so
if
would it be okay under those
circumstances to keep
the language as it is
um i would make the suggestion
respectfully of changing the word
campaign to outreach i think it
addresses dr terala's concerns regarding
how public health views the word
campaign and then i think it brings
clarity to the remainder of the language
if you just change that one word
if it's a if it's amenable to
the committee
um we would just make that suggestion
respectfully
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and if we are
going to be changing that from campaign
to outreach
um
is it the
i just want to get a general feel if
adding in that first pair first line of
the notice to read the state of new
hampshire obtained your private health
information when you receive the covet
19 vaccination without offering you a
chance to opt out so that it's clear
that it's just for that
uh
are we lurching our way towards an
amendment here
representative kenner
fair enough although again i think that
still would be
could prone to misinterpretation it
would you'd be saying during the copen
vaccine they obtained your public health
information your information and that
person might still think their entire
medical record went there um i think we
just be very straightforward and say the
record of your vaccination
has been retained by the state and if
you don't want that you can opt out
because that's the only thing we're
talking about there's no other
information so if we say
your private health information
without clarification they would assume
you mean their medical record i mean i
think it could be assumed and therefore
let's just say
record of your covert vaccination code
19 vaccination
uh
was obtained by the state of new
hampshire during your vaccination
but if we're going to do that we also
have to put in the words that if you
delete this there is no other record of
your vaccination available for you
in terms of
the date
uh what it was
and the lot number in case of a recall
because people need to know the
implications of the withdrawal
so that's a lot of work we have to do to
make this right if we assume that this
is just the bare minimum that has to go
in we don't have to birdsmith all that
we can let the department do it and that
was i think what everybody has agreed
and it'd be nice even the word campaign
personally
i don't
i don't get all bothered about because
it's it's it's not something that is
says that the banner has to say it's a
campaign we're just using a word
but i maybe i'm being sloppy but i just
i think we have to get this job done too
the question is how much do we trust our
friends at the table
to recognize our intent
trust is implicit absolutely and we
we're here trying to be helpful and only
because we just literally saw this less
than 10 or 15 minutes ago so we we
certainly honor and respect where the
committee is going we think this is a
great solution
and just would consider making sure that
your language mirrors what your
expectations are of the department
and thank you for your indulgence and um
and
thank you
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair a very very minor
comment uh on page two the word campaign
on line one
uh it would have to be changed if you're
gonna do that then you'd have to be
consistent
and have campaign changed on
page 2 line 1.
representative weber
i guess i need some guidance as to
whether we're going to continue
wordsmithing because i think that
um
i would disagree respectfully
with representative knurk i think you
can simply keep the words
the state of new hampshire
attained
information about your vaccination
status your covet 19 vaccination status
so we make it clear that that's what
we're talking about
without offering you a chance to opt out
of the registry
and then
in fact the vaccine registry and then
our new hampshire constitution honors
your right to privacy including
your medical information and you have
the right to withdraw your information
from the vaccine registry
and i do think that whether we specify
in the statute or not
there needs also to be a
a point about
if you choose to withdraw
your information from the registry
no further record
will be capped
you used the passive voice rather than
the active voice
and mrs casey always yells in my ear
when the passive voice is used
but i don't know whether people want to
pursue that or not
the chair has a par
probably a procedural question prompted
by the honorable clerk for the
parliamentarian
and that is if we have
significantly reduced the cost
does this still have to be an early bill
my opinion would be no but i would ask
you to run that by the house clerk and
the powers that made this an early bill
to begin with because
none of them actually listened to me
about these things
but yes it would it would seem to me to
be
easier but but that would have to be
approved by somebody else other than me
my thought being i was asking not so
much for ruling but for your experience
in matters similar to this that we could
certainly get such a ruling over the
lunch hour and if it is not
in fact any more an early bill
this can be reamended and looked at at a
later date
question is being under the gun right
would it be um acceptable
that we recess this bill to get that
information from the clerk and then take
this up in some form or another after
lunch
good
and chairman pearson if the department
could be excused thank you on this bill
we're
good
you're excused
we are putting this uh house bill 1608
executive session into recess to get
that information
regarding the bill's status now as an
early bill and that will speak to
how much wordsmithing we can do
open the hearing now on house bill 1536
fn relative to expanding medicaid to
include certain include certain
postpartum health care services
the chair rep
recognizes representative leon for a
motion
thank you mr chairman i move an
expedient to legislate on house bill
1536. do we have a second on that
i have done this out of order
there is an amendment
and i apologize uh
can we withdraw what th that
if if the moving party and anybody who
seconded withdraw they can but
my question is if the motion is itl
we would not be voting on an amendment
how does one know that if there's an
amendment
that comes first
how do we know what's next
there's no problem with you just
discussing the fact of an amendment
uh but
adopting an amendment and then itlling a
bill is not the normal procedure you
could you could discuss the fact that
there is an amendment you could move the
amendment
uh
but
normally one doesn't
move an amendment and then
itl it that would be the reason if some
if the majority accepts the amendment
why wouldn't they accept the bill as
amended is your point yes okay
um
then
with
you withdrawing this i
would like to discuss
the amendment because it is an amendment
from the prime sponsor
and that is
amendment 2022-0391-h
and you have that amendment you should
have that amendment before you
representative shapiro
yes the the correct amendment
the revised amendment is
0572h and i have copies for everybody
okay thank you
yes i am happy to withdraw so i can see
the amendment
so it's good to see what we have in
front of us i think that's fair
1536.
representative shapiro
i'd like to move that we adopt
zero five seven two two house bill 1536
we're going to hold on that until we're
gonna or we could just discuss the
amendment for that
sir having granted this i would like
this okay
this is gone
can i can i speak to the amendment and
what it does
give us a few minutes to read it okay
then yes
you
appropriation is added
and the date okay
got it
right
yep got it
yes but that's that's just been changed
no the only thing that's changed is the
date of the appropriation
okay can we come back now everybody
the only thing that's changed
okay i'd like to say that to everybody
okay um
the question is what's the difference
between the amendment and the original
bill representative shapiro it's your
amendment tell us
yes so the there are
there are two differences from that the
amendment um
creates one is it changes the
date that a medicaid state
plan amendment would have to be um
sent to cms
and that's on line 11
so it changes it to august 15th and in
the original bill
it said
october 1st 2022. now it says
august 15
2022 so it moves it forward a little bit
and the second change the amendment
makes is that it adds an appropriation
of 200 000 for the fiscal year ending
june 30th 2023
given i assume
uh the democrat
caucus has discussed this i know the
republican caucus has given those two
changes to either party see the need for
another caucus
we can ask some questions on this i
think before we move the amendment
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman and i have a question about
just some of these technical aspects if
a woman
let's say we pass this a woman
qualifies then is making more income
gets through this 12 months if she
becomes pregnant again before that time
period expires is she grandfathered into
another gestational period in 12 months
or would that new pregnancy require
separate qualification
even though she's already getting
expanded pregnancy and postpartum
benefits
i think maybe somebody else is better
able to answer this than me but but what
we discussed when the bill had a hearing
was the fact that
once somebody was on this 12-month
period of of
postpartum
medicaid that even if their income
changed they would remain on it for
those 12 months
so now you're asking if someone was to
get pregnant during those 12 months yes
yes i am um
i don't know the answer to that but
maybe i think there is someone here from
dhhs who's a medicaid specialist who
could answer that question
they've all gone to lunch
i think dawn landry is here
can't see everybody out there
oh yeah
sorry
let's answer that question
hi good morning sorry about that i was
thinking you'd be a little more direct
to the mic yeah sorry thank you
i was trying to dig out the policy
guidance from cms that does answer that
question
um
so if she does become pregnant again and
she's in that 12-month period she does
get 12 more months
it starts to clock over
okay
and thank you very much for that answer
i know that the
world health organization encourages a
24 month wait before pregnancies and i'm
just worried about that incentive too to
stay on it wasn't my intention but hey
that was me
representative shapiro well just uh to
the other side of that same coin is that
if someone
um remained on postpartum medicaid
um
for 12 months rather than 60 days they'd
be more likely to be receiving care
during that time and they'd be more
likely to
receive birth control and family
planning information
representative merchant
this is more of a technical question for
the folks in
dhhs
so if a
mother is pregnant and delivers the
child
in a ghost of 12 months and on 13th
month she becomes pregnant doesn't she
start all over again anyways
yes
so therefore whether she's pregnant in
the 13th month of the 10th month really
is becoming irrelevant because of the
fact that they're really independent
pregnancies one from the other
i'm not advocating for it but that's
kind of the reality of it yes and the
question from um in the cms guidance
does say the individual in this case
would receive continuous coverage
through the end of the 12th month
after the subsequent pregnancy ends
consistent with and then it cites the
federal law
so that's all right representative leon
i apologize i need to get better at this
being recognized thing
so that does mean that if a woman if we
extend it to 12 months she's taken a job
that does help l health insurance that
she's opting out of because she still
has medicaid if at month 11 she's
pregnant she then has the next pregnancy
and additional 12 months covered under
federal laws that we are bound to if we
do this
yes
thank you
representative
clerk
um
so there is
a
a woman becomes pregnant
in month 10.
so she just automatically gets
12 more
months
even though she may have gotten a job
that raises her above the income
eligibility and she has a job that has
insurance we're still going to pay her
12 months of medicaid
yeah so we currently do that for the
60-day postpartum well
60 days is a lot different than
12 months
just to qualify is your answer to the
representative yes yes yes okay
representative shapiro
yes i i understand why this is a um
concerning and
farthest from detail
um and
i wish we could i wish we could we
didn't have to follow cms and we could
just do it our own way
um however i would say that like
i do believe we're getting off on a
tangent that is a real exception and um
and i would and i would say that yes
there are people that are going to go
back to their wall street job somewhere
in the middle of being on medicaid but
that's going to be pretty rare
and
there might be someone who
is lucky enough to buy an unsigned
picasso at a yard sale and is going to
be um
in good shape for the rest of their life
and get a few months more months of
medicaid
but most of the people we're talking
about are not those people
um
you know i was reading in this morning's
paper one of yesterday's paper when i
was before i came
and i was reading about
paraprofessionals at winchester school
and paraprofessionals at winchester
school
are only allowed to work 34.6 hours
because of 35 hours they would the
school district would have to give them
um
health care health insurance and they're
not
they don't have the money to do it so
they don't do it so everyone works 34.6
hours
now if you
i just did the math and if you
worked as a paraprofessional with
some of our children or some of our
grandchildren in a public school and you
made 16 out an hour
you would still qualify for expanded
medicaid if you had if you had a couple
of children you're a single parent with
a couple of children
so i think we sometimes make assumptions
about people
who are on medicaid that aren't
necessarily
i wouldn't say they're not necessarily
correct but they're not necessarily most
of people who are on medicaid and
there's a tremendous amount of people on
medicaid who
who work hard
and still are
do not make enough money to to provide
health care to themselves and
and i think
these are the people
that this bill would make a tremendous
difference to
representative merchant
could you ask
during the hearing i heard because
conversation came up about somebody
winning the megabox
and
their obligation back to the department
with medicaid my understanding is that
if you have an income change
that makes you non-eligible that you
have to report that to the department of
human services so therefore this whole
issue becomes moot because once you get
to the point of being back on a higher
income that would disqualify them
at that point in time
by the virtue of notifying the
department of health human services
about their income status they would no
longer be qualified
not under the protected status for the
12 month we we would not look at their
change in income for a 12 month period
so therefore
we're talking about possibly again
legislating by exception so basically
what i'm trying to get to is how many
people
or do we have any stats about how many
people actually fall into that bucket
because if it's one out of a thousand
we're
regulating because we're making laws
based upon the exception of the rule
anyone else with a question or a comment
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
um i think we are
identifying some issues here as far as
the lack of affordability of
health insurance or health care
but i think our solution that we're
proposing here
is kind of going about it the wrong way
if we allowed more market competition in
the insurance industry and
we
encouraged alternative
forms of available health care
we could meet some of these needs
without having to put the cost on
taxpayers
and certainly uh
a representative merchant raised a point
but i i believe that it's inaccurate
isn't it true that during that 12 months
they don't have to report changes in
income right so
i just feel
that
this isn't the way to go about fixing
this there are other ways that we can
address the issues
at hand and without burdening taxpayers
representative folsom
thank you um
my question on this is is this a
12-month or nothing
kind of bill can we adjust the 12-month
period to
six months of postpartum care
and
would that
be even an option
representative shapiro you know i i will
um
take a stab at this and maybe um
dhhs has more information but um this is
not something that was invented by the
sponsor of the bill this is something
like
1578 where there's a federal
option in law
in this case it came with the american
rescue act
and so this is a federal option that's
allowed that states are allowed to pick
up
so my assumption
is that we can't necessarily shape it in
every way that we want to shape it
representative weber
could we please hear from ms landry
whether she has an opinion as to whether
we could adopt a shorter time period or
not
if she knows yes there's also a specific
question and answer from cms on that
issue and the question is do states have
the option to provide extended
postpartum coverage under the state plan
for a period of less than 12 months
response from cms is no the state plan
option provides 12 months of postpartum
coverage states extending postpartum
coverage under the state plan do not
have the flexibility to establish a
different postpartum period
thank you very much that answers the
question very clearly
this may have been answered along the
way but let me
just nail it down for myself
is the federal monies that
we could tap into
was this part of a specific bill with a
big part of money like we've seen or
does this look like this is now an
ongoing budgetary thing from year to
year
i would have to defer whether it's other
monies
to director lipman who is not here today
but this option right now under the
american rescue plan is only available
for five years
okay
so it would end
sunset unless federal legislation
extends it it would currently sunset on
march 31st of 2027
and given the
way of things that once
something has been granted it's very
difficult to ungrant it
it could well be that although at
present
some of the money to pay for this is
federal money
we may be facing in a few short years
the fact that we would be paying at all
given the way these things seem to work
uh representative
if you snow some of the medicaid
expanded medicaid services
federal funds also had not a 50-50 match
and a 90-10 match
does this
um there is flexibility in the cms
guidance um
to claim the enhanced match so if there
was a woman who was pregnant
she was in the adult in the expansion
group and she became pregnant there is
ability to
claim that continue to claim that
enhanced match but there is some
guardrails in there that cms is putting
up that we still need to have discussion
with cms on it might require um
also a state plan amendment to determine
the amount there the percentage of women
who
otherwise would have transitioned into
the
group
into the higher match
follow-up representative
i snow know why why am i the only one
that has trouble with this i don't know
anyway
in addition to that question what i
wondered about was
if you expand it to 12 months the kind
of problems that often occur that affect
the children in the mother sometimes
doesn't occur in the first 60 days after
delivery sometimes it's five or six
months later the postpartum depression
sets in the mother starts to ignore the
needs of her child and suddenly you've
got two damaged people
a child that's being ignored and a
mother that is going to require some
sort of care
and
i'm just wondering i can see a lot of
advantages to doing this
and somebody else must have thought of
this when they took the move under that
rescue plan to expand it
isn't it just they want to give some
money away i think they looked at some
of the advantages that would be held by
expanding it to 12 months and that both
the children and the women that are
delivering children would be and keep in
mind all we need is one child
ignored and ending up in a nicu right
after they come or later on having to be
placed in f
it doesn't take long to have enormous
costs in emergency room costs and other
things
outweigh
the savings that you develop by taking
this proactive step
sorry
representative canarch
yes i would like to expand a little bit
on that last comment
it is important to understand
that the costs don't go away
our entire health care system is
supported unfortunately with a system of
cost shifting
to cover uncompensated care to cover
well
let's not go any further there's a lot
of cost shifting that goes on and the
bottom line again
is the united states has the worst
maternal mortality rate of the developed
countries
and it's primarily because we do not
have good coverage remember over half of
our births are covered by medicaid in
this country
so this is not a small number of people
and
as we look at it
women have
just think of the physiologic changes
that occur in your body when you're
pregnant
this is one of the biggest events in a
human life
is to run through pregnancy
i haven't personally experienced it but
i've had a chance to observe it and also
take care of people with this and so it
is an enormous physiologic stress and we
know that there are a lot of problems
that can occur
during pregnancy and particularly after
pregnancy and the heart association came
and did talk about the risk of stroke
and heart disease and so if someone
is not getting proper care
those risks go up which is one of the
reasons we have the worst maternal
mortality
and these costs will not go away if a
person has a stroke
they don't suddenly at 60 days get all
better and require no care they may be
in a facility for the rest of their life
as and if they have their stroke on the
61st day
same thing
so the costs that we see are not going
to just magically disappeared because we
don't cover them or the taxpayer doesn't
cover them
we're going to be paying them for them
still through our taxes still through
our premiums of our insurance
because we as a society don't throw
people in the dumpster just because they
don't have insurance we take care of
them
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
so
just
following up on representative canarch's
comment
if a person has a stroke and finds
himself disabled they're no longer
working and then they're eligible for
medicaid
so
if something were to happen that
disables a person
after the 60 days of their pregnancy and
postnatal medicaid coverage ends
they would then
be eligible under a new condition may i
respond
yes representative i agree completely
but that's why we need the care because
the hope is to prevent the stroke
so the woman getting post postpartum
care you then notice gosh their blood
pressure is staying up
it's a lot cheaper to give somebody an
antihypertensive than to treat their
stroke if they're not getting care
you don't find it and we know that
chronic disease management of any sort
pays back very well because it's far
cheaper for example just take asthma
it's far cheaper to have somebody
getting their preventive care then take
care of them in the emergency room when
they can't breathe
may i suggest to the committee that
we're now starting to hear the same
questions and answers again and again
and
that's good but there's a point at which
we need to move on to something else i'd
like to call on two more people and
strongly suggest then we move along
representative merchant
thank you
in regards to the um
cms is this sort of an all in or all out
in other words
can we cap it going back onto what
representative folsom was saying
is instead of limiting it from 12 months
down to six months we heard that
through the guidance document
can you basically at that point in time
say that you want to cap it to so many
individuals is that a possibility
i don't believe that is
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and i actually
have one more question for the expert
here as well
it actually sounds like a lot of the
women who start off on medicaid in these
pregnancies remain on medicaid because
they are in some of these different
programs
like being the the paraprofessionals or
these other ones that that still keep
them within those thresholds do you have
any numbers about how many women
are
[Music]
or earn themselves out of medicaid in
that 12-month period because it seems
like we're talking about these edge
cases and um
i i know the people is it possible to
get that answer and then say a little
bit more drama to finish right now i'll
finish right now
and my biggest thing is i understand
that people are smart people especially
people on medicaid they are trying to
make
stretch a penny into a into a quarter a
dime into a dollar they are maximizing
every benefit and every opportunity that
we do and i'm just worried that this is
going to push women who are starting to
climb up the economic ladder into
shortening the timing between
pregnancies because it's a big economic
hit to let this go so if you know the
number of people who women who end up
not qualifying for it
based on income that would be a helpful
number although i'm yes
i do not have that number with me today
but we that is something that we can get
okay thank you i should have asked
before
may i float out the possibility that
reading the room which is not difficult
because we've been
a lot of us have been talking on this
for some time now
may i float out the up the idea that
perhaps an interim study to work on
these things would be acceptable or not
okay
so up or down
is the suggestion
yes
is this happening yes uh if i may that
during the multi-faceted issues that we
were addressing right here uh there was
there is a need that's defined then and
this is the first time this has come up
before this committee but to do it right
the first time i do believe a interim
study would make sense because we have
to have collaboration to achieve
consensus otherwise it's just not
happening and the debating point becomes
who's getting something for nothing
in my view
and
i am a believer that in
providing resources
to
to ensure health
and therefore have a better result than
waiting for something greater to happen
and then dealing with that result i
found that to be a true negative um that
and that i've learned right here in this
committee uh dealing with uh disability
issues and also help and then bona fide
health issues that are quite broad with
all of us i do believe as a result i
would ask my colleagues to consider an
interim study here with an aggressive
committee to be put together and to have
a a plan that's called has a cooperative
collaboration to achieve consensus on
this subject
thank you mr chairman
if we may uh talking about that question
of interim study rather than the bill
itself which i think we've well talked
through representative shapiro yes just
a question of the chair so if if it was
um
either unanimously or in a split way
went to interim study
when
when would be the earliest that could
come back
i would ask that to representative weber
who's more knowledgeable than i
an interim study committee makes a
recommendation
generally around october or november
to the next legislature
they are allowed only to say recommended
for future legislation are not
recommended for future legislation
they're certainly allowed to specify
what they think is good for future
legislation but any future legislation
has to be filed by a member of the next
legislature and considered under the
next legislative schedule
representative folsom
when a interim study is done
and they gather
more of the facts figures numbers data
all of that
um because several questions have come
out about that
can they present that
then to the or
make that available for the person
offering the bill the next time around
it's certainly
the right
of anybody who was on the interim study
committee to offer the information to
anybody they want to offer it to but
there is no formal mechanism that i know
of
that
preserves that data and a record unless
somebody decides to do it themselves and
hand it on to the next person
looking for thoughts
nods
you know i must admit i'm torn on this
there's a there's i really am and i
don't like to be torn on things
representative webber do you think we
might want to caucus over lunch
mr chairman
if if you want a caucus that is your
absolute right
i would argue
that
the need is great
the
children are innocent
the saving potential savings
greatly outweigh
the potential expenditure
so
i would argue
that we ought to just go ahead and pass
the bill as with the amendment but
that's not
my call to make that's the call of all
of us and
so it's up to you how to proceed
i'm going to be
calling a caucus of my party
in a few minutes and
recess further consideration of this
bill until after lunch
so we will meet back here at one o'clock
and
um after the room has been cleared if
republicans could stay here for about
five or ten
of minutes
so it was probably somewhere around 150
to 200.
i probably this one said the average for
25.4 days
a little bit better
you know
it's good to give all those details
i mean for some of them
financials
full time
okay
are you having trouble unloading eggs
how
so you make egg powder
here
bill number number
there is but i don't think we're voting
on it
no we had we had an amendment i think
they're just going to vote to send this
into a study
i mean we'll see
is right thank you
um
we have been discussing this uh reopens
the hearing on house bill 1536
and we have been in discussion
and i think we're pretty well discussing
everything we needed to discuss
so the chair recognizes representative
leon for a motion thank you mr chairman
i move house i move interim study on
house bill 1536
i have a second on that
representative cushman
discuss your purpose
um thank you mr chairman
when we look at this there's absolutely
unmet needs of women who are falling out
of the current medicaid system
we do need to make sure that we're
supporting them as they're returning to
work but we also need to make sure that
whatever we're doing to follow the
federal government is the correct choice
for new hampshire that we're meeting
these needs correctly
and that we aren't going to be
incentivizing women who have used their
pregnancy as a springboard back into the
workforce and to higher paying jobs that
disqualify them from serial pregnancies
conceiving again before those 12 months
are up because
people follow the incentives and it
would be a pretty clear path in order to
avoid a very large expense to your
family
this is something that we need to make
sure that there's not a big moral hazard
here and
taking this to a true interim study
where we meet together and work on this
and try to figure out how to address who
these edge cases are
both on the ones that would be included
that perhaps shouldn't and those that
that are falling through the cracks
is the best way to address this and make
sure that we're supporting our citizens
and future citizens so we're moving i i
made the motion to interim study
any further discussion
it was seconded by representative
cushman
representative weber
thank you mr chairman um while i
appreciate the willingness to study
i
am unable to agree with the underlying
premises
stated by
the former speaker so
uh i will be
voting against interim study because i
think that this is a bill whose time has
long since passed that we need it now
and that to delay
is pennywise and pound foolish
that we will
avoid significant costs which will be
born either by the taxpayer or by other
insured citizens
and that this bill would avoid
significant costs down the road so
i will be opposing the interim study but
thank you
thank you representative representative
thank you and i would agree i think i
would agree with representing leon that
do people do follow the incentives the
savings that a person might achieve by
being able to stay on medicaid and
therefore not perhaps having to pay
their insurance for a short time with
their employer their contribution which
might be a small amount or might be a
very large amount
will be relatively small compared to the
average cost of raising a child in this
country to age 18 which is currently a
quarter of a million dollars so if they
do follow the incentives they will
probably not get pregnant to save
perhaps
five to ten thousand dollars at the cost
of a quarter million dollars
thank you representative
i was really torn
about this bill and
realized that if there was a forced
choice yes or no i would reluctantly
vote no but no i would vote
and my sense is that would be not
because it's my vote but my sense is
there'd be more no votes than yes
and
i really wish that some work could be
done on this so i can vote yes in the
future which is why i am voting interim
study
anyone else wish to speak representative
shapiro
yes
i'm glad to participate in interim study
group
but i think that
you know my my gut feeling is that
we're putting it off for a year whether
we itl it or interim study it and
there's not that much difference it's
it's a clearly delineated program
because it's a federal option so there's
not that much wiggle room in terms of
what we do here in new hampshire it's an
option that we can take or not take
and i also would say that i personally
find it offensive that
people would talk about people because
they don't have money that they would be
incentivized to get pregnant right away
to keep medicaid i find that really
offensive
i find it offensive sir that i can give
you some names of people who have done
just that
anyone else
then the motion before us
is interim study
house bill 1536
interim study was moved by
representative leon and
seconded by representative cushman
please
clerk call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative renzullo
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk no
representative salloway
representative cannon
representative nutter
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant
no representative pearson yes
11 10.
the motion
carries interim study 11 to 10 will you
write the blurb thank you
and representative shapiro thank you sir
and
um
one second
and your motion will be
as amended thank you i i have to write
it down they always ask me if i don't
yes i have that thank you
7-7 think it's zero five seven seven
oh i have seven two
oh sorry i i guess i have something
different that's a different bill oh
you're correct
okay
open the exec session on house bill 1662
related to privacy obligations of the
department of health and human services
there is an amendment
zero five seven seven h check to see if
you have one because i've got a stack of
them but they do not look like there's
enough of them
2022-0577
[Music]
h
that's the one dated today
with your name at the top
so
let's
check to see
that's all i have
um we've got
there's some more copies
to see if you've got one
before asking for one
oh thank you
he gives me my second one for the file
and as you look at this amendment it
does carry the name of representative
edwards representative merchant did a
lot of work on this the reason his name
does not appear
is when ols needed to do work on this
you got to get the
sign off by the chief person who was in
committee at the time so we will give a
big shout out to representative merchant
for his work on this amendment as well
as representative edwards who i know
carried the day long and hard
when this was in the possession of
oversight committee um
how would you like gentlemen to
introduce the amendments if i could mr
chair um the chair of our subcommittee
was representative soloway yes and i
would like to have representative
soloway speak to the amendment
and if he needs the assistance from
myself or dennis i think that would be
that we could help to support him
thank you
um
i'd like to give you an overview
and then i'd like to turn it over to
representative merchant and if the chair
will permit to representative edwards
though he does not sit on this committee
his role
in crafting this amendment was so
significant that i would like to ask
permission for him to speak as well
well first of all sir i think that's a
splendid idea and secondly i will grant
it for no other reason
than to atone for my oversight and not
recognizing you first because you did
indeed chair this committee so yes
that does not mean mr chairman that i am
a bad person however there are other
kinds of things they imply however
that in a
cork board with a number of tacks i am
not the sharpest of those
it is a praise offering not a sin
offering to use the temple terms
so um
dear colleagues
um the initiative for
this bill
came out of the uh
committee on oversight of the department
of health and human services
it's actually a very significant bill
and it speaks to some of the issues that
have been brought up earlier
in particular by representatives leon
gay and cushman in discussing uh 1608
and that is the issue of privacy
for our constituents
the
oversight committee for dhhs
thought long and hard about the data
that our constituents provide
and how to safeguard the privacy of that
data in particular for those
constituents who may or may not care to
have their data included in a state
database
as a result of that
we wind up with this bill before us
and i must thank
not only representative edwards who did
yeoman's service on this
representative merchant representative
acton and representative kufal who uh
all of whom contributed significantly to
the thought that went into this
so
there was a section of the original bill
that spoke to the issue of opt-in or
opt-out of data
and
representative edwards schooled us i
used the word advisedly
in the differences between line and
staff functions
and it comes it stems out of his
significant military experience and what
he points out is
that you can put structures in place
and you can put operations in place the
important thing for us on this bill
was to put into place a structure
for guaranteeing privacy
the details of the process of doing that
will be coming to us
after crossover
uh on a in a bill
authored by senators rosenwald and guida
who sit on the
oversight committee of of of health and
human services
i have conferred
with senator guida and asked him
pointedly is that bill going to pass and
are we going to see it in our committee
after crossover and he assures me that
that will happen so what i want to
convey to you
is that our role here today
is to consider if we can put a structure
in place in dhhs to guarantee privacy
with the confidence that we will then
get the opportunity to discuss the
process
of guaranteeing privacy when we address
the senate bill
and that should satisfy
i think everybody's needs
i'd like to turn this over to
representative merchant who
really provided significant input into
the sources of data
and then
to representative edwards and i'd like
to indicate to you that we had we met
in deep conversation with mr gagnon who
is the privacy officer currently and
with mr weeders who is the data man for
dhhs so we've really processed in detail
so with that i will turn with deep
respect to my colleague representative
merchant for his comments to be followed
by representative edwards
thank you represent i also want to
recognize representative acton
representative culpald yourself and also
representative edwards commissioner
goulet along with mr weeders because
they're very instrumental we spent a
considerable amount of time going
through this and with the guidance of
representative edwards doing the
wordsmithing we're able to accomplish
the amendment that we're proposing for
you
where the changes lie we get to some of
the detail
if you go back to the original bill it
listed if you will
each position
there wasn't any alternative
for that so therefore what we did was we
still listed them but in the quorum if
you go back and look at the quote
number two line 26
members may delegate the authority to
represent who they are
to maintain a quorum so we're not
looking to have a designee on the top
level but build that into the quorum at
the bottom number two we also said that
the commissioner has to be the chair of
this group
and that was important because as the
commissioner they should be the one
chairing this
quorum in this meeting at the same time
we allowed for the chair in the event
that the commission could not attend
they could appoint somebody else on
their behalf to be there
if you go back and look at
we took out the section about the opt-in
and opt-out as representative soloway
basically said this is a structure issue
not a policy issue and to complete the
two is going to be problematic we have
the opportunity and we will have the
opportunity to talk about the policy
issue when it comes across on the senate
side and we can deal with the policy
side when it gets to us at that time and
not complete that with the structure
in regards to the other thing we talked
about some certification if you go back
into line three
sorry page three on line five
certification and talking to people
it was determined sometimes it's hard to
find people in the i.t world that have
the appropriate certifications so
therefore we allowed for them to be
hired but require them to be certified
within a certain period of time after
they're hired
the other thing was on line 11
we talked about the issue about the pay
grade
in talking to mr weeders and people in
the i.t world a pay grade 27 was not
going to be sufficient to hire the
talent that we want so we have
increased the pay grade paid grade 35 we
also put in appropriations of 254 000 to
cover the cost of that for the
department so those are basically the
changes that we made within the bill
they were in my opinion sort of minor
except probably again the policy one was
probably the biggest one but like i said
before that's coming across to us we
will
see it again and we'll have an
opportunity to act on it
and i don't know whether
representative edwards or episode of
acton if you want to add anything to
this as well
thank you representative
i'm certainly new to the creation of the
structure of a governance board so
but i do want to say that this was
it was an honor to take part in this
because it was a master class of taking
disparate positions
and melding them together finding
compromise and coming out with
what is really a um
a well-produced
bill here and um so
part of that is is is representative
edwards's um insistence that we keep
this at a high level
but also compromising to keep it at a
reality so that is realistic for the
people that are that are being tasked
with being part of this
um as well the the quorum
the discussion of quorum was something
that i had had never
um
really thought much of but that's
there's so much to it that i i didn't
realize and and finally the the
um allowing the the hire as an i.t guy
allowing two years to get the
certifications need to get allows you to
go find the right person and then let
them get these specific it
security
licenses and and certifications over the
two years i thought was a brilliant um
compromise to get to find the right
people to do this so um very impressive
and
something i learned a lot from
thank you
representative knurk
yes i just want to make certain you went
through over the various things it does
but i want to make sure i understand
with clarity i i think i do as i compare
the two what it no longer does
it does it appear
uh take out
the language uh for the opt-in opt-out
which was initially on the bill was on
page two lines 19 through
and it appears to also take out the
language on page three lines 10 and 11
that required that uh
that
you'd have to have this plan before the
before anything could happen but it did
have a nice
issue about on the amendment on page two
line 30
it points out it's still a good date uh
for when it is that
uh things need to be in place to start
collecting data so is it correct that it
is removed that opt out and update now
you mentioned the senate bills but this
amendment does remove all that language
privilege that it's a good catch yes it
was an oversight my
part in not bringing it to everyone's
attention on page three on the original
bill we did remove lines 10 and 11
because at that point in time for the
state and federal funds
we didn't want to lock the department
into a situation where
they may not be able to respond to it
accordingly thank you
uh
thank you um
i uh i think i think the folks on your
committee have pretty much said
everything uh i i would like to uh
respond to um a concern uh that about
one thing that we did
that has ruffled a little bit of feather
and and i hopefully not so much that
it'll entice
um uh
opposition but
um we had a discussion uh how much it
should be exposed to the public how much
it should
uh solicit public information
by way of having a public member
appointed by the governor
and i think what the working group
coalesced around was that
since the privacy right was established
in 2018
we're still very early on in the
maturity model
for privacy within the department
and
um and if you read some of the uh
requirements that we're imposing on the
board part of it is just to get educated
you know there's a lot to learn about
privacy principles and there's a lot of
discussion
about security techniques and the like
and
it was it was my belief and i think it
was shared fairly widely that having
this be an internal
looking
committee initially
would allow them sort of the space
to have serious conversations to admit
what they don't know
you know and and to get smarter and be
put themselves in a position to where in
four or five or six years
that's about the amount of time it's
going to take for this governance board
to hit its stride in my view
so so i just assume let the
ugly growing pains of this kind of be
behind closed doors now now it isn't
without some oversight specifically we
have hhs oversight that you know is
chaired by your chair
that can look into pretty much anything
and so i would expect that the oversight
committee in the coming years would
check in on how this governance board is
developing and can review some of the
privacy impact assessments that are new
documents for the most part for the
department and
to the extent that
we
learn things we can there's always
future legislation we're never really
done look at the medical cannabis for
example how much that's changed over and
over and over and changed over time so
so i don't think we need to do this just
once this is landmark uh legislation
let's get it in place
um
part of what we tried to do was to do
this in a way
in which the department
uh could support it and i've been told
mr weeders can
you know throw things at me if i'm wrong
but i think the department mr williams
uh
supports this
amendment
which is good because i don't want to
have to worry about the governor vetoing
it if we can get it through the
legislature so so and and i think the
doit the commissioner of the department
of i.t
likes this bill so much that
he's going to begin implementing some of
this at the state level and there was a
discussion that we had
whether or not we should just do this at
the department of health and human
services level or go ahead and take a
big bite and go for the state right away
and and so kind of out of an abundance
of caution we just wanted to take one
step at a time and there's nothing that
prohibits the uh commissioner of i.t
to uh leverage this work and leverage
the lessons learned uh and he said that
one of the things that
he's thought of as a result of these
conversations for the last six seven
eight months
is he wants to establish at the state
level um a chief privacy officer
um not more than half of the states have
chief privacy officers all of them are
new within the last five to ten years so
it's kind of
an emerging trend for government to
worry about privacy so so i think i
think we're at a nice point um on that
uh wave so
if there are questions i'm happy to
answer them questions from mr edwards
representative gay
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking this question
i marked when we first when we first
studied this bill
that lines on page
two lines 19 through 30 were not are we
on the amendment just so i'm tracking
the original because i don't have the
original one okay well it's not in the
uh the new amendment
it that dhhs did not like lines 19
through 30 which are notice consent and
data subjects
all personal information
yeah
the first part says all personal
information both manually and
electronically collected shall be
collected on an opt-in basis
i can understand i can be talked into
accepting that that will take a while to
work in
but after having worked in a company
that
you know their business was
uh
writing software
i can tell you they
they don't like surprises later oh after
we've already built this now you want to
add this in and how do we you know if
we'd known we could have made made it so
there was a place to insert it so is
there any plan ever to uh put in opt-in
uh thank you thank you for the question
um
there
there's always an opportunity to add to
the legislation as you know but i think
more specifically what we heard earlier
is that the senate has a bill coming
over that has opt-in
built into its language specifically for
the closed loop referral system which is
one of a multitude of i.t systems but
that one got to be particularly uh a big
group of particular interests because
the closed-loop referral system is meant
to
interconnect the uh
the whole um system of care
of community-based care being
coordinated and everyone getting the
wrap around holistic
services that they need and because that
system would share personal information
theoretically all over the state
although practically that wouldn't
happen
but it did raise the concern
so so the closed loop referral
excuse me the closed loop system
closed loop referral system there we go
the closed loop referral system has its
own legislation coming
um and and it's going to get debated and
and the opt-in is part of that
and and and i just also want to just
point out that
um
there has been in my experience for four
or five years whenever the discussion
opt-in opt-out has come up
um the department has pushed back
against it the legislature has been a
little
ambivalent about it in terms of it's not
been a fully bipartisan position
so we haven't been clear
but i i think increasingly
the
the department is hearing us
when we talk about the value of opt-in
and so i it's my hope that if if if this
really takes off like i wanted to this
governance board can institute their own
opt-in policies
thank you
so that
the
software won't be built based on this
this this document is structured of
people
and systems
but the software my concern again is if
the software is built and then we say oh
we really want to opt in on at least
certain certain aspects yes ma'am i can
clarify this a little bit maybe this
will help
uh when you look at the i.t portfolio
all of the it systems that dhhs is
responsible for managing
and then you add to that all of the i.t
systems that the department of or the
department of i.t the state level
manages on behalf of dhhs you're talking
scores of systems
and almost all of them have their own
privacy issues so what this bill is
meant to do is say let's establish a
governance board that that cares about
privacy and then let's
implement something called a privacy
impact assessment which is a particular
form of risk management
methodology to where each it system gets
looked at and evaluated based on its
unique privacy issues and i.t security
issues and so
um so i think if we were to come back
and revisit this in five years the
department would have gone from maybe
one
privacy impact assessment to having
a library of as many as 40 of them
so and each of those 40 would be
related to a particular i.t system
now the best way to your point about
you know retroactivity
we're trying to get them with these
privacy impact assessments to do them
before implementation
of a new system or a replacement of a
new system so so by doing it in advance
of implementation
they will have the opportunity to
consider opt-in as one aspect of a
defense in-depth approach to protecting
privacy
does that help
representative merchant did you want to
speak to that
no i'm all set i think representative
edwards entered it answered it very
eloquently thank you thank you any other
questions for
any of the committee representatives
soloway merchant or edwards
mr chairman are we due for a motion
um i was just thinking this would be an
excellent time and i was pondering in my
mind who might wish to make a motion on
this very amendment i would like to make
that motion sir
as the titular head of the committee but
by no means the brains behind it
and i would like to move ought to pass
i can relate to the difference between
titular and brains behind served very
well
this is the amendment this is the
amendment
this is amendment
seven h now moved by representative
soloway and seconded by representative
acton do we need uh yeah we do actually
any further discussion maybe not
nope
yes yes hi
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
i've got a list of grievances i'm sorry
um
so i don't support removing the opt-in
opt-out provision especially if we're
trying to guide the department on which
way to go with their new systems
[Music]
if we're serious about privacy we should
be making sure that every system used
within our government that collects
private information about
uh citizens is
truly
private and that there is an opportunity
to opt out of that
to opt in sorry
um
we need positive consent
uh
if we're going to have growing pains
behind the scenes
i think it also provides
um you know
or it it prevents
accountability
to the people and i had speak spoken and
i appreciate
representative edwards's
viewpoint
on
allowing the growing pains to be behind
the scenes but i think from the birth of
this
it should be open to the public these
should be meetings where the public can
give input whether that's in a you know
10 minute public comment period at the
end or even just submitting written
comment
um but i think that the minutes don't
cut it that they need to be able to see
the interaction the discussion how it
all goes down how the decisions are made
and there's plenty of opportunity to go
into non-public for those sensitive
issues of security and
private information on people
um if this is landmark legislation and
we are just
we want to give them a little bit of
time behind the scenes to have those
growing pains
then there should be
something in this amendment to make it
open to the public within six months or
a year or two years
and i don't see any of that and so for
all of those reasons i will not be
supporting this
anyone else
the motion before us is amendment
seven 2022-0577h
to house bill 1662
the motion is on a pass
moved by representative soloway and
seconded by representative acton would
the clerk please call the roll
representative leon this is the motion
on the amendment on the amendment this
is the amendment yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative
gay representative cushman now
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king
yes
representative franzulo
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes
representative pearson yes
18 to 3.
the motion
18-3 motion carries 18 to 3. the chair
will now
call on representative mcmahon for a
further motion
mr chairman i motion
out the pass as amended
for house bill 1662 with the amendment
zero five seven seven eight very good
looking for someone to second
representative merchant i will second
that
thank you
any further discussion
the motion before us
but before that
my clerk reminds me
22 people signed up for it and seven
against it
keep doing that
okay
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended house bill 1662 fn
as amended by amendment 2022-0577
h
otpa moved by representative mcmahon and
seconded by representative merchants
would the clerk call the role please
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
renzolo
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay yes representative
snow
representative nerd yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
18 3.
the bill passes otpa 1823
would representative mcmahon write
the majority report please well mr
chairman i was going to suggest that the
titular head of the committee
with his uh presence at that meeting
would be an appropriate
one to write
the narrative because he could add
additional detail that i was not present
for
not only is he the titular head he is a
font of wisdom
thank you sir
now of the three of you who voted no who
would like to write the no report
all right so um
was that leia or who's doing it
and your motion will be
okay thank you
we did we read that
um we don't have the blue sheets
this is what the office has told us of
people who have signed in
so that's all we get
i s
did you hear that
no what do you mean
that is what you wish for the menard
okay change that
that's a better motion
okay we still don't have that thing
coming
well i have a i have a cushman amendment
here
what's the other one
and 1608.
not yet
no we haven't yet
amongst the three of us
okay get out 1604 please
1604 including state medical facilities
in the statute providing medical freedom
in
immunizations
we
have an amendment before us
20 22 0 5 5 4 h
brought to us from by representative
cushman um
does everyone have a copy of that
amendment
we do is where is it
it's in the shuffle
and before i forget representative and
thank you for this
the original bill because they didn't
see the amendment the original bill
512 people signed in in favor of it
and 95.
signed in against it
1604 what's up next we i thought i'd do
that before we all forgot
one second
okay we're still short on amendments
okay
you have more anybody have spare
because i just gave away my second and
you're so generous you need one for your
folder though that's that's gotta get it
back
uh
i can run and make the copies
so let's how long should you think about
this no she's got this
[Music]
okay she's got them
she has
no you don't have to
you got that you've got hardcopy
on what they may or may not do
did you give us the wrong one
is mine
open the executive session on
house bill
1604 please attend to amendment
2022-0554
[Music]
because if this passes this will become
the bill
representative cushman would you present
your amendment please
thank you mr chairman
if you'll recall uh
hb 1604 fn
seeks to repeal
section e
of the second paragraph of rsa 141c
colon 1
dash a
which would allow that medical freedom
from immunizations
statute to apply to our county nursing
homes new hampshire state hospitals or
any other medical facility or provider
operated by the state of new hampshire
or any political subdivision they're
under
this bill we came up with some issues
regarding cms there were some concerns
um i've been in touch with
some officials across the country
who deal with cms including
the
um
the national association of
medicare or cms surveyors
and the way this it that
florida has passed a law that
contradicts the cms mandate and it
allows for additional exemptions that
are not required i mean not permitted
for the cms rules and arkansas has also
passed a similar law and so far there is
no issue with cms and they are hopeful
that in the future cms is going to
adjust the rule to articulate better
with the varying state laws
so this
allows instead of a blanket shall be
free from
for those cms certified facilities it
instead offers a streamlined exemption
process
and you'll see it starts
in i'll just read it from the beginning
so this
the
uh medical freedom from immunization act
shall
shall not and then it begins on
line five apply to a county nursing home
the new hampshire state hospital or any
other medical facility or provider
operated by the state of new hampshire
or any political subdivision
identified in paragraph one of that
statute which is subject to a valid
enforceable medicare or medicaid
condition of participation that imposes
a vaccination requirement
so that means there it still doesn't
apply to them however such facilities or
providers shall upon an employees
contractors patients visitors or
students requests for a medical
religious or conscientious exemption
grant such exemption the written request
for exemption shall simply state i
requester's name hereby submit a request
for a medical religious or conscientious
exemption from the required vaccinations
and it shall be granted
there are 60 days for it to take effect
so they'll be able to figure out how
they're going to
implement it
questions representative
merchant
thank you
i'll raise the same question i raised
during the hearing to represent cushman
in the event
that uncle sam decides not to send
monies to the state of new hampshire
because we violated
the rules and regulations
i don't see a fiscal note here that
would say the state of new hampshire is
going to cop up the money
to back fill all the providers because
if i'm a provider and i'm looking at
this i'm caught between a hard place a
rock and i don't know which way to go
if i'm relying on the federal government
to provide me with reimbursement for
services
and i don't have those dollars coming in
i then can't maintain my services to my
constituents and to our residents here
in the state of new hampshire so would
the
folks be willing to write a
bill that would basically say the state
of new hampshire will in fact
keep you whole
thank you for the question um it's not
necessary because right now cms is is
going forward and reimbursing
facilities that are not surveying on
this requirement of the cns cms mandate
in the states that have laws that
contradict it they're still reimbursing
for services there they've been told by
those states that the state will
continue to conduct their surveys as
they have and just not including that
piece of it as a part of the survey
and and it's been going forward fine and
they anticipate that
instead of on the con um
how do i say it not
in
instead of withholding funds they're
more likely in the future to be
adjusting their their requirement to
allow for this different state
laws so that they don't contradict
representative shapiro
this is thank you mr chairman and thank
you for
taking my question this is the smallest
of questions i'm just wondering why it
includes students
sometimes students are clinical
yep they do so medical provider students
thank you
representative connerk
um
the the problem i have with this is that
the
rules from cms
don't say that they're going to
immediately stop the funds they will
first notify that you're not in
compliance
they will try to work with them
i think it might be a bit of a pipe
dream to assume that their response will
be to modify the requirements
rather than enforcing what they have
actually
written as a mandate and the last step
in the mandate is to stop paying
so i think that is a very distinct
problem and i really don't think it
should be our
choice
to become the test case
for a uh
for this issue of whether or not they're
going to withhold the funds unless we
are prepared
to go ahead
and backfill those funds we'd have to be
prepared to do that
secondly the other reason i markedly
disagree with this is because it does
gut out everything else
that is in 141 c1a ii
um
i think that is correct because it
repeals it and writes it with only this
and there are some very important things
in c 141 a 2.
it
i'm sorry thank you
thanks for that clarification that makes
me feel far better okay but i still
would stand with my initial comment that
i think we would have to be prepared to
backfill because that is what they
cms
plans to do there's no reason for us to
think that they would not
well i have ample reason to think that
they would not because i've been
speaking with officials who work with
cms across the country
and who have been dealing with this in
their state and cms has not made any
indeed they've instead made more of an
indication that they're going to
adjust the rule in the future
to articulate well
with the varying state laws because they
anticipate that there will be more
states following florida and arkansas
and it would be
you know it would not be look very good
on the federal government if they go
ahead and close hospitals for
control over exemptions
representative and line 12 of the
amendment when it says
required
vaccinations do you know what
vaccinations
are currently required
in for cms
well in new hampshire nursing homes or
yes the cova 19 vaccination is required
for the cms that is the only vaccination
there is also influenza but the
it's not the same kind of mandy
what's that some how about polio or some
of the ones you need for school no no
none of those are required interesting
representative weber
i'm just going to cut to the chase
whatever we think cms is or is not going
to do about the funding
this applies to the
places where we treat
medically
or
in a mental health
environment
the most vulnerable populations of our
state
and
while there are many other places where
it would be appropriate to allow
opting out of
vaccination
this isn't one of them i think it's
perfectly dreadful health policy i think
it's perfectly dreadful for our senior
citizens who are in nursing homes and
i'm opposed to it so i'm going to be
voting no on the amendment i'm going to
be voting no on the bill thank you
representative shapiro
just to clarify the earlier point about
whether this applies to just covered 19
vaccinations i i do believe that the
attorney general
made a statement that that whole
medical freedom from immunization bill
only applies to covert 19. so i think we
are only talking about covert 19.
it's only covered 19. i think that's a
good point yes
in any case
i would also like to just
echo what representative weber is saying
which is that um
regardless of um
having funds held i just think that this
is a policy that should be available to
um
medical institutions that are dealing
with
incredibly vulnerable people and um
so i'll vote no on both the
amendment and the bill itself also
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman uh just a couple
of quick points um i
of course like all of you i'm a member
of my county delegation i sit on the
committee for our nursing home and given
who i am they rely on me fairly heavily
for
issues of epidemiology and infection
control
our county nursing homes in our
new hampshire state hospital have worked
incredibly hard to keep covid under
control the most effective tool that
they have had is immunization we don't
want to compromise that tool it's item
one
second item um
i'm in touch with
people nationally who are tracking the
epidemic of covid
in particular i heard yesterday from
mike osterholm who is at the center for
infectious disease at university of
minnesota i have some training at
minnesota i know these people
and
he says uh and and i absolutely trust
him that we have passed the peak of
covid
we are watching the numbers drop they
are dropping precipitously
we don't know what the next threat is
going to be
however this is probably an inopportune
time
to be fiddling with
what has been
reasonable success at dealing with the
outbreak this is just an inopportune
moment to fiddle with this again our
county homes don't want this new
hampshire hospital doesn't want this
let's just leave it alone
thank you
the chair would like to call joe
christie from nhh he is here on the cms
compliance issue
uh if you would come up please sir
i guess good afternoon sorry get our
secret shot at it now the mike's on
[Laughter]
uh for the record joe crissy chief
financial officer and legislative
liaison for new hampshire hospital and
glencliff home
did you want me to speak to the cms
mandate i apologize sure okay um
so
as we understand it the cms
coven 19 vaccine mandates for hospitals
and nursing homes
uh
there's kind of two sets of deadlines at
the moment there is the initial original
deadlines
for any of the states that did not
participate in any of the lawsuits at
the federal level against the mandate
for the states that did participate
our
our final dead deadline is march 15th of
this year
so
at the moment uh facilities in our
predicament are in the process of uh
becoming compliant with the mandates
and so for that reason they're actually
i would say certainly in new hampshire
there's not been any enforcement of the
vaccine mandate up to this point because
the deadline has not yet come
the
guidance that we have received to date
does indicate that cms wishes to work
with facilities as much as possible
to come into compliance and that's
that's pretty well articulated through
their guidance
but they're
it does kind of end at a certain point
where they do start to talk about
termination of participation in cms
programs accreditation things to that
effect and
essentially at that point you also start
to lose your funding as well so
they can withhold funding before you
lose accreditation if they so choose
that is part of the accreditation
process for a lot of facilities um or
can be part of the accreditation process
it's it's very rare in occurrence but
um it sounds to me like there's mercy
but don't presume on it correct
okay
representative canarch
i would also like to point out that i've
pulled up the cms guidance and it has
guidance regarding requirements for
exemptions
and their basis for medical exemptions
and they list them they have to have a
process for medical exemptions
including documentation
which is signed by a licensed
practitioner
for they have to have the basics of
religious exemptions that they must have
a process to request it and they have to
be documented
and they do not have any exemption for
conscience objection
so the difficulty is if we
have if we do what's in this amendment
we will again be violating the guidance
from cms regarding conscience objection
and also since this just simply says it
shall be granted it doesn't require any
of the documentation that cms
requires therefore i would assume that
we would if we chose to do what's in
this amendment we would be out of
compliance with this guidance
and that would put us at risk as they as
has been pointed out under enforcement
they talk about what they will do they
will cite the
facility they'll provide an opportunity
to return to compliance then they use
enforcement remedies such as civil
monetary penalties denial of payment or
termination this is from the cms
guidance
i think again we're playing with fire to
pretend that just because florida hasn't
gotten in trouble yet and i think the
reaction which is not even being fully
enforced that that means we're clean we
are not
and i think that they would not have set
this mandate if they didn't mean it and
the supreme court again has
ruled that and they their wording was
quite clear that they support the
concept that since cms is paying the
bills they have the right to set the
policies which they do for infection
control in any number of other settings
for their facilities
i'm not their facilities i'm sorry
places they pay
and i've taken the role of chair um i i
will actually recognize myself here just
to point out that the supreme court
just stayed the injunction this is not a
final ruling so this is something that
is still in process so there's not yet a
final ruling may i respond to that
because it is that is true but if you
read the whole ruling they very strongly
supported the concept that cms cms has
the authority to do it so if it works
its way back up to them i i there it
would be unusual if they would not
support it because their wedding was
quite clear in their decision i read the
whole thing
as far as that goes the questions may be
around exemptions so that's why we're
still discussing this i still have the
chair
representative folsom please
thank you um representative knurk i was
trying to listen really carefully as you
were reading that um
so i just want to clarify for myself
when with the exemptions they're asking
for documentation
is that documentation from the person
getting the accept exemption
or does the facility just have to have
documentation saying this is how many
religious this is how many
i answer that
yes
the guidance says
it's basis for medical exemptions
facilities must develop a process to
permit staff to request facilities must
ensure all documentation is signed
and dated by a licensed provider so that
means the documentation has to be signed
by a provider the documentation must
contain all information saying why the
19 vaccine is clinically contraindicated
so for the medical it's not just they
have to document how many medical they
have to the the documentation of why a
medical exemption is being granted must
be clarified signed by a practitioner
explain why it's a problem for example
that they have an allergy to a component
or something like that for religious it
also says they have to have a process to
permit them and it says that they must
ensure that all requests for religious
exemptions are documented and evaluated
evaluated in accordance with applicable
federal law and as part of the
facilities policies and procedures
so that does not just mean that they're
giving the numbers it means that they
have actually when somebody applies they
have to document yeah i just wanted to
clarify that because you read through it
so fast i wasn't quite sure i was trying
to keep us moving
representative weber
thank you i'm going to raise another
problem which again is let us back out
of the weeds of cms and look at the
patients who are involved
if we adopt this which applies to our
county medical facil our county nursing
homes and the state hospitals
and i think the glen cliff home is
really the only other one
what we are doing and and remembering
number of people and it's a number
greater than half in the united in the
state
who actually support
mandates and support
the mandatory the the vaccination not
mandatory for the person but mandatory
for people who choose to do the work in
nursing homes in the state hospital
what we're doing here
is
we are creating
a two-tier system of care so that if you
can afford private pay
for a nursing home or private pay
for a mental institution that has a
policy that you agree with
you get to be cared for in a way that
makes you feel safe
and unexposed or less exposed because we
all understand that no
guarantees are made a hundred percent
but
those among us who are the most
vulnerable
generally speaking the most sick
generally speaking the most ill
are subject
to a regime in which
the minority is opposing their will upon
the majority
and the majority has absolutely no say
in it
and i think that that's reprehensible i
think we are sacrificing
in preserving rights to some people we
are sacrificing the rights of our most
vulnerable citizens to safety
and that's also a paramount right and i
think that to adopt this would do them a
great disservice and we'd be creating a
two-tiered system of care which i also
think is reprehensible thank you
representative cushman
thank you madam chair
as far as being able to mitigate
infection we have ppe nothing in this
bill prevents ppe from being used
nothing prevents screening nothing
prevents testing
it's just that people have a
streamlined process of exemption we know
that under the civil rights act of 1964
religious accommodations and
accommodations for medical conditions
are available to those who
uh request it
and that facilities can then require you
know increased screening or additional
ppe or even assignment uh reassignment
of position if they
feel that it's necessary
and they can prove that um
that it wouldn't
that it uh that it is necessary so
there's no guarantee in any
because we have the civil rights act
okay we have we acknowledge the rights
of people to exercise their religious
beliefs we acknowledge the rights of
people to be accommodated for medical
issues that prevent them from receiving
a vaccination the problem is that it's
becoming a religious inquisition and as
the state we're setting the standard and
we need to say that this is not okay
and we also need to allow our
constitutional right of conscience which
the our state constitution says is
unalienable it can't be given or taken
away we need to provide for that and we
need to set the example in the
state-owned medical facilities
and as far as
a two-tier system
we're basically saying if we
if we
if we don't pass this
you know that the state
acknowledges that if you don't buy a
pharmaceutical product and you don't
consume that and even though it's
irreversible
that you can't be a nurse and you can't
be an lna and you can't be a doctor
and that you you know you're not worthy
of those positions and it's just not
right
and we need to come out as a state
and set the example for the medical
facilities that we run
i'm going to take one and mr kuroso
right now are there a certain percentage
of workers in our county nursing homes
the new hampshire hospital and the clint
glencliff home who are working even
though they're unvaccinated
um so i can speak to new hampshire
hospital on glencliff home i don't want
to speak to the county nursing homes
just because i i don't represent them
and i don't have insight into their
vaccine statistics i'm at new hampshire
hospital in glencliff home our staff are
around
it's easier to say who we know is
vaccinated than not
because those who we do not know are
vaccinated
may have been and we just don't know yet
so both facilities are around 84
fully vaccinated and fully vaccinated is
either two doses of one of the two dose
vaccinations or one dose of the the jnj
um
and around 87 percent have received at
least one dose um so there is a portion
of staff who are we are actively
engaging with to understand have they
received a vaccination
before and uh we're just not aware of it
or um are they pursuing an exemption or
something to that effect
oh thank you and are we seeing any
higher rate of transmission within the
new hampshire hospital and glencliff
home than we see in other areas
um
i would say no um
i don't know if that's a
easy comparison because there are so
many factors that go into infection
mitigation within a healthcare facility
um we've i would say
i'm proud to say we've actually i think
done a pretty good job at managing covid
in both facilities we haven't had any
major adverse outcomes um and our um
we're very proud of gwen cliff they went
uh i think over a year before they had
their first infection so
they did a phenomenal job in that regard
that's fantastic representative merchant
thank you
as a hospital when i worked in the
hospital
before i retired
there are vaccines that i had to
receive in order to continue employment
can you explain or talk to us about
other vaccines that hospitals
require their employees to actually have
one of the things we had back at that
point in time was
flu vaccine and you had a choice of
getting the flu vaccine and wearing a
mask and so forth you had to have an
exemption for it can you speak to some
of the other vaccines that are required
today by some of the hospital personnel
sure
in my a little over a decade of
healthcare experience at
multiple employers some within new
hampshire some outside of new hampshire
all of them have required some form of
vaccination there's kind of a standard
series of measles mumps etc
and
those
those are kind of a standard part of the
orientation process i would say at
virtually any healthcare facility such
as a nursing home or a hospital
representative gay
thank you very much madam chair um
four things hit my mind one is
vaccinations are the only
method that we are told that in order to
work in a medical facility
that we're told that's the way to
protect them
but we all know now that vaccinations do
not guarantee protection they are good
for four to six months after you take
them
natural immunity is not recognized by
cms and we know that that is long
lasting
they've tested people from the 1918s
while they were still alive in their 90s
and found that they still had protection
effective medications are prohibited
they are still prohibited
even though they've been through like
160 clinical trials you still see
reports that say
they need to be tested
statistically they can be analyzed if
you will look at dr mobine syed's
website where he interviewed dr
the doctor who was here from virginia
dr merrick
they analyzed they went through
study after study it was all very sound
statistical
evaluations
theirs has been in existence
for at least decades
and this
vaccine is different from all the
predecess predecessors
very different
more
vaccine-injured people have been
reported to bears for this one than the
sum of all the others ever
so i think it's very short-sighted just
to follow cms rules because
they're not following the current
science
and i do think safety is worthy
it's not just what my freedom is is my
freedom going to impinge on somebody
else's health
but the point is we have a whole lot
more
uh tools to protect people that are not
being used that are being ridiculed and
that's why it turned into a political
thing which it never should be medicine
should never be political but it got
politicized
and uh people suffered as a result
because they were denied medication and
they still are
so that's why i
think that
simply loosening
or not loosening but making getting uh
applying for exemption is a fair thing
we can still protect people vaccinations
are not the end-all and certainly not
adequate
representative acton
thank you madam chair
i have some pertinent uh
i hate to take it back to cms but uh i
have some pertinent experience with this
uh
i worked i was
i.t director for a company that
ran afoul of
cms based on
incorrect paperwork that was
submitted for reimbursements
and
what they do is they they don't tell you
there's a problem all of a sudden out of
the blue
they claw back the money
and that destroyed
a 70 year old company in new hampshire
it caused 40 layoffs
in in a matter of weeks we were taken
down and
we didn't even know it we didn't and we
couldn't appeal it you couldn't get
anyone answer the phone
so it is likely given the
given the
supreme court
ruling and the way they're heading into
this and some political
politicization that they will
come after us
um having said that
representative gay makes some excellent
points
and uh i got to tell you i'm leaning to
um
i don't know how i'm going to vote on
this yet but i'm worried about seat i'm
worried about cms they are
uh not um
i'll withhold my my opinion
but they it's likely they will act
thank you
representative pearson thank you madam
chair
we're in uncharted waters and we've only
been in it for two years
and a study says this and a study says
that
and i don't think that's because people
are being bad i think because we are in
uncharted waters and not only that
things are changing too
i have on a
microcosmic level
2 000 patients at our medical center
which is not huge but it's not nothing
and so we get to watch unfolding before
us
all of this shifting sands and he said
and that expert said and oh by the way
the guy in the gym told me
and maybe he knows something
maybe he doesn't
one of the hardest things in ethics
is when there's conflicting virtues
who wins in case of a tie
my mom
not the worker at the nursing home
in case of a tie in case there's doubt
in case there's a possibility
i don't want
my mom my other loved ones who are or
who have been in such facilities
to take the risk
that going with natural immunity or
ivormectin or something else is
sufficient i'm not willing to gamble
a lot of people are hiring out there
to say we're going to keep restrictions
on you and the nursing home does not put
somebody out into the street jobless
there's lots of jobs out there and you
know what this all may change in a
couple of years but i have to vote this
afternoon
and i'm going to vote for the
restrictions to stay in place
would it be appropriate for us to call
for a caucus
we could do that okay
i don't know if they want to but uh
we'll recess forever
hours
absolutely we'll recess for that for
just a moment
i can
share anybody
your comments were incredibly
lucid and right on about creating a
two-tier system i think
absolutely
is
i don't think we've had it moved yet it
has not been moved
all right merchants all away we need
another upper
foreign
the ranking member and i have come to
agreement that we would like to move
forward now on this we've discussed this
at some
length and the chair calls on
representative cushman for a motion
thank you mr chairman i would motion
pass on amendment
2022-0554-h
and do we have a second on that
representative gay
the motion before us is on amendment
four 2022-0554-h to house bill 1604
f and the motion is ought to pass made
by representative cushman seconded by
representative gay
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative renzolo
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay no representative
snow no representative nerk no
representative soloway
representative cannon representative
nutter upham
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant
representative pearson yes the amendment
passes 11 to 10.
representative cushman for a second
motion
i would motion i would move that
house bill
1604 fn be
ought to pass as amended
do we have a second
representative leon
the motion before us
is house bill 1604 fn as amended by
amendment
2022-054-h the motion is ought to pass
as amended
moved by representative cushman seconded
by representative leon would the clerk
please call the roll representative leon
yes representative mcmahon
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative renzolo representative
delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk no representative
soloway representative cannon
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant
no
representative pearson
yes
11 10 11 10.
representative connert for the minority
report and you want to do them
okay i'm sorry
yes itl would be our emotion
thank you for giving me a moment there
to put that back in the right spot in my
brain all right this ends the executive
session on house bill 1604
and we've got a couple left are we ready
with any of that this 1608 just came
back from ols i sent it up to house
committee services we have 12 24 as well
they're both ready um this one is the 12
24 is printed
1608 is ready but not yet printed well
then let's do the one we have copies of
open the executive session on house bill
1224 fn
in the original prohibiting state and
local governments from adopting certain
mandates in response to covet 19.
prohibiting employers in places of
public accommodation from discriminating
on the basis of vaccination status
amendment
0575-h
is coming around
it's not 12
44 which is sitting on our seat you're
we're doing 12 24.
12 24
did i say 1244
oh okay
oh
is there more than one amendment
so
so it is amendment zero five seven five
and it's a replace all one oh no
replacing section two i apologize i
misread replacing section two
and representative leon would you
introduce it to show us
as we do a side-by-side comparison
what's different
yes thank you mr chairman this bill as
introduced had both restrictions on
government and restrictions on private
and private industry
this amendment limits it just to
restrictions on government so section
one which is only prohibiting mass
mandates
remains
and i'll mention speak to that later
once we move to the section two the new
subdivision if you look at these
on the original one lines 16 through 20
are struck those are the ones that are
about no person in this business doing
business in the state shall require
patrons or customers
then when you move to line 23 of the
original bill
it strikes person or so that this limits
it to a governmental entity
this is in regards to the unlawful
discriminatory practice based on
vaccination status
line 27 of the original bill
moves from an employer to a government
employer so limiting this just to the
government
then on page two lines one through three
are deleted because those are referring
to public accommodations
so when we look to this
it is limiting it just to government
we've had a lot of discuss about safety
versus efficacy
and
while we agreed to disagree on the
efficacy over ivermektin and kovid
the truth stands to bear that there are
more data to support that than there are
to support the fact that a mass protects
anyone other than aware outside of a
health care facility in a health care
facility they make they make a
difference
and that is not something that comes
into play because
those are not the state or local
government agencies those remain health
care facility decisions regarding mass
use ppe always should be in the hands of
those facilities because that is how
they manage risk
and
this is narrowing it to the fact that we
are government and we place restrictions
our job as legislators is to determine
where the rights of government end and
this is placing limits we already have
state preemption on on other aspects of
life and we tell that we tell our local
government that there are certain things
that they can't touch
so that's what this would do
representative
weber
thank you and while i appreciate the
limiting this to state government i
think there are still significant issues
based on
concerns of local areas what works for
manchester does not work for cheshire or
coast counties
and therefore
and we don't know what the next thing is
coming down the pike
i think basically that this is
really bad health policy and
i am going to vote no on the amendment
although i do believe it makes the bill
better i'm still going to vote no on the
amendment and i'm going to vote no on
the underlying bill representative
soloway
thank you mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen i am pleased to inform you
that this bill written specifically for
kovit 19 has missed the departure of the
sailboat that vote has sailed and if you
choose to rewrite legislation on general
infectious disease
that might be useful but writing a bill
specifically on coven 19
you missed it sorry
is it your assertion that by the time
this wins its way through the
legislative three weeks mr chairman
three weeks the government
so that's yes to the question i'm trying
to ask
it's over
by the time we get to the floor the
numbers are going to be so low and we're
going to say oh why did we bother
your red gown from bu doctoral program
sir
as you are sir
representative kenner
fair enough i still have some concerns
for example the language in the mask
mandate says to minimize the spread of
covenant 19 or any other infectious
disease
we should not tie the hands of our
public health experts in terms of
responding
to this or to the next upcoming
problem
uh the
if we have another
infectious disease that is highly
contagious and there is good efficacy of
mask wearing
all of a sudden we lose one of the
options that the public health
experts have to use to mitigate
that
secondly strictly reading that
would say that we also our nursing homes
which are run by the local government
would not be able to put in a policy of
requiring their workers to wear a mask
or the visitors to wear a mask because
this says
any rule or regulation regarding it
regarding coping 19 or any infectious
disease
another point that is troubling the
thing although you've made the language
certainly far better in the lines in the
amendment of i could say 15-22
when we say a governmental city cannot
deny
employment we're back to the same
problem we just talked about with the
cms mandate
our governmental entity of the county
delegation
and county
commissioners run our county nursing
homes
the government runs our new hampshire
hospital
they would then not be able to do
anything regarding vaccination status
they would now again be out of
compliance just as we discussed on 1604
that is going to be a problem
and uh let's see so this is
that would have to do with all of the
lines of 15 through 22
i would think
um
yeah so i this this amendment still
has problems it is better than the
underlying bill
but it
has it's far too broad ties the hands of
public health
and
will
put us out of compliance again with cms
and i think
this
again this one because it doesn't say
covet 19 specifically in the
lines 15 through
20 it talks about vaccination status
that would also again also preclude
vaccination for some for the next
upcoming disease that we do not know
what it is if covet has taught us
anything it's to teach us that our
public health has to be nimble the
countries that have been nimble in their
response to dealing with it have done
well those who have been sclerotic like
we have been in terms of instituting
what needs to be done have not done well
is mr charisti still here
i'd like you sir to address the uh it
was mentioned that this amendment would
put us out of compliance with cms and
since this is your a field of expertise
with you could you address that please
sure again for the record my name is joe
christie cfo for new hampshire hospital
glencliff home
so relative to the mask mandate portion
of this bill that is of concern for new
hampshire hospital and glencliff home we
do require our staff to wear
masks when in the building we also
require visitors and so forth
and we are considered state agencies so
i do believe that it would apply to us
um
relative to the
uh vaccine portion of this bill i was
just reading it i apologize i'm not as
up to speed on this bill as i was on
1604 this amendment just came out today
thank you
but if it were to apply to government
entities then yes it would
either government or healthcare or
employers i guess whatever the the
wording is in that bill
that would pose the same problems that
we
previously discussed
thank you sir you're welcome
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman um
i live in keene and in keene we
currently have a mass mandate and we had
one and then it expired
and then about a month ago
um maybe a little bit longer um it was
put in place again
and that involved
being brought up at the city council it
involved many many people coming to
testify people who were adamantly
against mass mandates adamantly against
masks and vaccines people who were for
them
in any case there was a rigorous debate
some of the counselors
who introduced this were very much for
it some were against it some were
ambivalent and it was a long democratic
process
and they did extremely democratic
extremely rigorous process that led to
our town having a mass mandate
and um i think that we should be able to
decide for our city
and that i think um
the process not only left us with a mass
mandate which i thought was useful but
it also promoted local democracy which
i think
i'm in support of
for the record before i forget
thank you
what is the vote telly well i thank you
for asking sir i was hoping you would
the original bill
not the amendment but the original bill
579 in favor and 156 against
representative canark
one more thing i failed to point out if
you look at line 23 that was the
amendment on the amendment i'm sorry on
the amendment line 23
that will also remove our school
immunization requirements
because right now we have immunization
requirements for children to
attend school for communicable diseases
this would remove that because we would
say that there can be no
discrimination regarding the vaccination
status so those would be gone as well
i don't know sir if this is anything in
your wheelhouse or not but you know if
you feel like you wish to as an expert
witness chime in i'd like to hear from
you
relative to the
i'm sorry oh what we just said or
anything before or anything you think of
i think that uh
as i've stated before i think that the
prohibit prohibiting masks
relative to state agencies can impact
infection control practices in our
healthcare facilities within the state
so
and and i would also i guess add to my
previous testimony that's not just new
hampshire hospital and glencliff home
that could also apply to sununu youth
center the department of corrections
virtually anywhere within our state
government in which health care is
rendered
relative to the vaccines i think
i
i don't know if i have more testimony
than what i've offered previously
i think it's a real risk
it's one that i'm personally concerned
about for our organization in terms of
not just the financials but our
accreditation and
really our infection control practices
thank you so much and um oh dear come on
up
abby
yeah i know that
dear abby
i can never forget her forehead but i
just did
thank you for allowing me to speak um we
i just wanted to make a comment on
representative conner's point on the on
the amendment on um i don't have it in
front of me but what would affect line
23 related to
um refusing um
uh
services oh thank you very much
representative cannon
um okay so yes so on the amen on the
amendment um 2022 0 5 75 h
just wanted to point out on
line 23 where
um
it uh public oh sorry
anyway where we would talk about um
denying someone educational services
based on vaccine status that would be a
very large concern to the apartment the
department related to keeping the very
important school requirements for
vaccination in place for school
attendance and we just wanted to point
that out that that would be a big
concern to us we were here testifying
yesterday on hb 1035 a bill that you
heard yesterday on that subject so the
chair wishes to state that
in his intention because you see my name
at the top of the page
lines 23 4 and 5 should not be there
and i may well have to vote against my
own amendment
because a public accommodation is now a
restriction
on
some guy's pub
and it says not just
coveted vaccines in school but polio
vaccines in school
so i do apologize these things do happen
but i was taught to clean up my own mess
and i
do not stand with this amendment as you
have it before me because of those three
lines representative weber
thank you mr chairman i'm thinking
in light of the concerns
with this amendment including the
concern
that it might prohibit health care
providers run by the state
from taking exactly the same kinds of
mitigation measures that we were told
would help
if we allowed them to not require
vaccines in the earlier bill
so we have the earlier bill which says
you don't have to be vaccinated
and then you go into the county nursing
home and say and i'm not wearing a
stinking mask either
because you have that right under this
would that
would that be of concern to you
that's a very large concern to us um
certainly in the new hampshire hospital
in the glen cliff home for those that
cannot be vaccinated certainly for
medical reasons they would have to have
that extra mitigation measure of being
able to wear a mask
and
mr chairman yes you may continue
my follow-up comment is just a comment
for the committee
given the concerns about
real functional internal issues here i
can't even begin to think what would
happen with the department of
corrections for example
would this perhaps be a bill that ought
to be referred for interim study and
another of those committees that worked
on it very carefully to balance the
equities in a way that we are not going
to be able to do in
the time left to us
i don't know who that was for but i'll
say sure why not
could i make a motion
one one second please representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman i i just want to
weigh in because i i do see the the
issue there with not being able to
mitigate infection in any way you can't
if if you can't require mass in a
medical facility and i support the
motion interim
thank you so much appreciate that
may i make a motion or or i would defer
if somebody else wanted to make a motion
representative go for it uh i would move
on the amendment
no because i'm going to we have an
emotion in front of us i'd
oh did we move the amendment over we
didn't
okay then i would move into and study
amendments
yes we nev
okay we pulled the amount i did not
offer the amendment so your name is on
it
so i would move interim study at this
point okay interim study is the motion
thank you so much
these things happen those of you who are
new to the house
these things happen
interim study has been moved by
representative weber i would like to
second it
any further discussion
seeing none
the motion before us is house bill
1224 fn
the motion is interim study moved by
representative weber seconded by
representative pearson
would the clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
yes representative renzolo
representative delemus yes
representative weber yes representative
mccabe representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
salloway representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes representative woods
representative merchant
representative pearson yes
19 to 0.
let me think a little bit about who
might write the blurb on that
i've thought about that for a little
while
and i think representative leon would be
good to write the blurb on that okay
yes consent thank you
yep
this concludes the um exec session on
house bill
24.
now we should have
up next one
1608 our remaining one unless we do a
couple of others but 1608.
then let's just do 16.08
i would very much appreciate okay
the amendment is
537 i see one that's also 587
587 is the correct amendment this is the
one that was shaped after our discussion
earlier
it changes
the word
campaign to outreach on page one line 29
um
wait a second let's get to get
everything
going out here and find the original
bill
yes thank you so this um on page 1 line
29 we changed campaign to outreach while
we sent in the language with line 1 on
page 2 saying outreach it still says
campaign but i think they can probably
follow the dots there
then the language that the public will
read
now reads as the state of new hampshire
obtained information about your covid19
vaccination status without offering you
a chance to opt out of the state
immunization registry our new hampshire
constitution honors your right to
privacy including your medical
information and you have the right to
withdraw your information from the
immunization registry
if you withdraw from the registry the
state will not retain a record of your
vaccination
the department's still free to add if
they believe that that language is clear
and nobody else might have it but we're
trying to keep the language as limited
as they might need just in case they
roll off of a banner and it becomes
another set of pixels thick and it
starts obscuring the other information
so they have the opportunity to say and
nobody else has it if necessary so this
i believe comes from a conclusion of
what we did before and hopefully this is
to our agreement
any questions representative weber
i thank the representative for the
amendment and i think it clarifies
things significantly and i think that
perhaps whoever writes the blurb
can
explain that
it is our intent that if
dhhs needs to add
clarifiers they may but they are not
required to do so
i would like the clerk to read
the sign-in information
and you'll be surprised by this
oh yes
okay those that uh signed in in favor
was zero
those that signed in opposed is zero
it's a tie
and i don't believe that for a minute
but that's what i got he really trusted
me with some you know hard stuff
mr chairman and members of the committee
i'm about to lose friends on all sides
um but when you've done that in the past
we met up with you very quickly because
we like you
thank you mr chairman
um
data is extremely important and
extremely useful
when it is accurate
and then it can be used to make policy
making policy on inaccurate data
is not only foolish it's dangerous
in a recent unpublished study to which
only i and three other people have
access i'll explain it afterwards if
anybody needs to know
it was a study of data gathered in
florida on vaccination status the data
was completely totally and utterly
unreliable therefore worse than useless
dangerous
given that
i'm
all in favor of the amendment i'm all in
favor of the bill
commissioner shibanet appeared before
the
committee on dhhs oversight and said
specifically
our data is really inadequate
if you have inadequate data you might as
well not have any data and you might as
well give people the freedom to withdraw
what data they have given thank you for
listening
this just in
from house committee services
we have an update on the number
on house bill 1608
online stats
347 support
11 oppose
one neutral
i cannot speak for the entire committee
representative soloway but i still like
you okay
there's a second over here too by the
way
i can yeah
i can call the role
i think we should let's have
representative gay introduce the emotion
hasn't been
okay
what
we pulled the last one but we have not
moved this one
i move otp
to
amendment
seven 0587hp two house bill 1608 fn
thank you do we have a second perhaps
from
our friends over here
representative shapiro seconds it
any further discussion
yes representative acton thank you mr
chair um i just want to relay a
finding i had with data collection
earlier in my life
after the earthquake in haiti i had the
idea of going down i was working for a
prosthetics company as an it manager
um i had the idea after the earthquake
to go down try to get a head count of
how many people had been
received amputations we had seen in the
media of
ten thousand twenty thousand up to
eighty thousand they may well have been
so but how many had actually survived so
we went down and we thought it'd take us
about a month to collect this data so we
started going field hospital field
hospital throughout the disaster zones
about two weeks after the earthquake
by the second day
where we had only collected maybe 10
percent of the data we were already
making accurate predictions
on how many people had actually made uh
received amputations so we we estimated
after only collecting a small amount of
data
after we finally got it all collected
the total number was about 2300 so we
were actually very
accurate and we only collected a small
amount of data so i don't think you need
so i don't understand this push to have
of all this data you can make
you can make remarkably accurate
predictions with smaller data sets
so i just wanted to put that out there
thank you
just mention for what it's worth we
liberal arts people have been
ballparking things all our lives
any other comments
all right the motion before us
house amendment 2022
house bill 1608 fn moved by
representative gay and seconded by
representative shapiro would the clerk
please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative renzolo
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway representative cannon
representative nutter uppam
representative shapiro yes
representative woods
gone
absent oh abs i'm sorry and merchant is
also absent representative pearson yes
19-0
now don't make the same mistake you made
this morning okay now the bill as
amended
could i have a motion from someone for
otpa
oops i'll move ought to pass as amended
by
20220587h
and the second
representative
with representative cannon being owed
one for a future date
any further discussion
the motion before us is
house bill 1608 fn as amended by
2022-0587h
moved by representative leon seconded by
representative nada oppam
would the clerk please
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative renzolo
representative delemus representative
weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro
and representative pearson yes
19 to zero and this is when i ask
would there be any objection to it going
on consent
shouldn't be seeing none thank you and
the committee report to be written by
representative leon
you know i'm kind of glad we ended after
this tough day
with a 19 to zip
i really am i mean we do a lot of good
work sometimes it doesn't happen
but we always hang in there together
representative kenner yeah just a quick
question or favor i would say
because time will be of the essence of
getting these committee reports to you
we want to make sure that there's no
missed committee reports
if the clerk has kept a list could could
you just very quickly read off or if
somebody's kept a list
the bills we did today and who is
responsible so there would be no
confusion where somebody
doesn't get it to you and then you have
to chase him
um i do appreciate that because i'd like
to get this on the calendar for our
sessions next week absolutely if we
could just hold just a moment just one
second sure
no i just want to be able to grab them
as she says it's so that i'm going to
confirm what she is saying um and if
there's a mistake then we catch it now
okay
go for it
um house bill 1642 uh representative
kanark
house
bill 16 1654
representative king
start again 1642 is canary yes
1654 is king king
1130 is weber
just watching over there 15 26 is snow
and i already have it from him he got it
to me a day see this makes up this makes
up for any possible difficulties with
the microphone you're welcome okay
actually by the way would you also say
who's doing a minority report if there
is one
i don't know
i don't think any of those have one but
just if that would be there'll be a few
this one does uh 1578 majority acton
minority shapiro
majority leon
1662 majority soloway minority cushman
1604 majority cushman minority canark
sorry 1604
thank you for the correction
um
1224 leon
1608 lay on
i have a lot of writing to do just so
we're laying it on i hope you guys don't
get sick of me
although it'd be fun to exec a couple of
bills i think those are ones where i
would like as much as possible to have
the full committee here for that
and but uh next time we meet um
we should be ready to go with 1099 and
and by by next week there may well be a
couple more we can do
i know some of the uh committees are
working subcommittees are working hard
on amendments
and there we go so next week's going to
be
really
busy yes
mayor remind members that the
subcommittee
on hospital visitation policy the number
of which i don't remember will meet at 8
30 in the morning
on tuesday
to take up that
that's 14 39.
and represent representative weber i
assume that you're part of that group
if you would like me to resign as chair
i would be glad to but you seemed to
want me to do it so i did and i we've
already put the notices in
uh
if if i need to say essential would you
stay on his chair
i was kind of planning on it
well good because i asked the house
committee research office to do some
looking around and they've got a report
that i'll be happy to give to your group
uh if anybody is working thank you for
that welcome i'll see if i got anything
else nothing immediately
yes representative soloway
just as kind of my closing statement for
the day the president of the
congregation appeared at the hospital
bedside of the rabbi
and informed him
that the board
had voted to wish him
a speedy recovery and it passed 17 to
14.
uh thanking you for your earlier life in
the borscht belt doing good and to you
know you opened the door for jewish
people to be in the entertainment
business and i thank you for that
okay folks we're finished thank you
you